I will see you Saturday yes and I'm
seeing you here today
exactly
yeah
thank you very much I'd like to start
the
public hearing of the uh
January 25th uh
the meeting first meet uh the uh
actually the second meeting of the
resources Recreation and development
committee
I'll open the uh
open the hearing good like please please
stand and assess first salute the flag
foreign
thank you
probably next time we'll move this
system into the corner so
people are not saluting me
yeah my back
thank you
first on the agenda is house bill 212.
thank you very much Mr chair and good
morning everyone
um
I provided written testimony on this
bill that should be at each of your
places I'm not going to read that but I
do want to highlight some key points
about this bill it's a result of
discussions of from the HB 737 pfas
commission which was a commission
established by Statute about a little
over three years ago to study the health
and environmental impacts of pfas
contamination from the Merrimac
operations of cincobain there was
legislation that passed two years ago to
expand that to include the towns of
Londonderry which has discovered to also
be impacted so the four communities of
Merrimack Litchfield Bedford and
Londonderry meet monthly we also meet
part of that commission includes
representatives from Des DHHS UNH USGS
UNH and there's a couple environmental
scientists on there and um
every year we prepare an annual report
for the governor the speaker the Senate
President some others about what our
legislative and non-legislative
recommendations would be this year the
committee came forward with three
legislative recommendations that
involved funding funding to secure that
testing is done funding to ensure that
the state is is equipped to manage
upcoming mcl's drink for drinking water
coming from the EPA
um and just also to be equipped to uh
look do perform scientific investigation
about the extent of pfas contamination
all of these three things don't just
impact that area but they do provide a
benefit to to the state so um with
discussions with Mr Mike wimsat from Des
we decided to bundle these
recommendations into one bill and which
comes before you as hb212 what it does
it does several things one is it expands
the current pfas remediation Loan Fund
which was also established by Statute a
few years ago I believe it's funded now
at least 50 million dollars that fund
provides low-cost loans and some grants
Mr whimsat could probably correct me on
this and I think there's also some loan
forgiveness aspect to that bill for
people that are suffering from well
contamination and it helps provide
monies for them to install systems which
stands for point of entry treatment
systems
212 would expand that loan forgiveness
Bill to also include two million dollars
that Des would have to address pfas
contamination testing investigation in
the state and thus it would also rename
that bill the pfas response fund
um I I want to thank Mr wimsat very much
for his technical assistance in drafting
this bill and I would be happy to answer
there any questions from members of the
committee
I thought I'd have my bill more time to
organize the cards
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Mike wimsat I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and with me here today is our
pfas coordinator Amy Russo and uh we
appreciate the opportunity to come and
testify in support of this of this bill
so as representative rung indicated
um this is uh a bill that came in a
large part out of discussions um that
occurred at the HP 737 commission which
as she stated me you know meets monthly
and has met monthly for a few years now
to really try to get its arms around
um what's happening in Southern New
Hampshire with regard to pfas
contamination and how the agencies of
both and New Hampshire DHHS are
addressing the concerns in those
communities
so for us pfas is very important in
Southern New Hampshire but it's really
an issue that the the
includes the whole state we have uh
challenges in both Southern New
Hampshire and Seacoast but really pfas
because of its really ubiquitous use in
products exists contamination exists
throughout the state it's more severe in
Southern New Hampshire as a result of
some industrial discharges that occurred
but it is an issue that is really truly
a Statewide issue and the uh again we
support the expansion of these allowable
duties under the pfas remediation Loan
Fund the
it's important to understand that really
since 2016 when this problem really
reared its head in Southern New
Hampshire Des has been directing
resources from multiple areas to try to
understand the extent of the
contamination and really our main focus
has been to either reduce or eliminate
exposure of our citizens to pfas
contamination much of that has been
associated with drinking water and so
our Focus has largely been on drinking
water and drinking water treatment and
and testing as well and uh the Pea past
formation Loan Fund really has to date
been targeted specifically at that and
really nothing else
alongside that since 2019 Des has had
the benefit of a six million dollar
appropriation that was uh in the in the
in the in hb4 the the Budget Trailer
bill that occurred that year that was
passed that year and that gave us
specific uh funding and a directive to
do uh testing monitoring sampling and
research associated with not just pfas
and drinking water systems but across
all media because we do see it we're
concerns about it in both groundwater
drinking water surface water air
soil and biota and and the food that we
so we've done we've used those funds in
large part to really a lot of those
funds have been have gone towards
testing and that's been the biggest
concern is that because of the
ubiquitous nature of these we need to do
testing really anywhere so at this point
anywhere that anyone asks us we
generally are able to go and Sample
their well and understand and find out
what the pfas concentrations are on the
well and then help them through a
variety of other programs address that
if it's found that they're well as
contaminated and that's an important
part of what we do we've made great
strides we've done thousands of Wells
that we've tested over the last several
years but the need for that work is
still very great there's a lot of work
we still have yet to do and the that
that appropriation that happened in 2019
has been tremendously helpful but it
lapses in five months it lapses in at
the end of June of this year so what
what this bill would do would be to
expand the the sort of the reach of this
remediation Loan Fund to also include a
directive and an authority for Des to do
this additional work that I've just
described and really make this pfas
response fund as it would be renamed if
the bill passes a comprehensive tool and
resource for the agency to continue
doing this very important work
we don't take a position specific
particularly on the source of any
appropriation that's that's you know for
the legislature and the governor to sort
out in this year's biennial budget
process but we're certainly very
supportive of um you know providing
additional funding and expanding the
scope of the pfas response fund to to do
this work and with that I'll be happy to
answer it along with Ms Russo to answer
any questions from members of the
committee
thank you so much for coming to
thank you so much for coming to testify
representative McHugh from Merrimack
um and thank you representative wrong
for bringing this bill for our community
um so what I'm hearing you say is you
support the bill but not necessarily the
funding
no I'll thank you for the question I
want to be very clear about that there's
this this is something that you will
hear I think from Des as a familiar
refrain there are a number of bills that
come before the legislature this year
um that do provide an appropriation for
funding and I think consistently what
you will hear from Des staff who testify
on those bills is that the agency is not
taking a position on the appropriation
and that is not that's nothing to do
with the importance of this fund or the
work that I've just described that's
across the board we recognize that the
legislature in the governor's office you
know the lecture is going to hear from
the governor around Valentine's Day his
budget proposal and they're going to be
working very hard over the next several
months to determine a lot of multiple
priorities and we know that there are
you know the regular funds available and
there's Jennifer and surplus funds
available and there are multiple parties
vying for those funds with many
different purposes and reasons and from
our perspective as a regulatory agency
we're not taking position on that that's
really we see that as the purview of the
legislature in the governor's office and
we're just simply not taking a position
on the Appropriations because you know
that's something that the legislature
sorts out and and we don't we're not
really trying to enter The Fray on that
I guess is what I would say I hope you
don't in any way take it as any lukewarm
enthusiasm for what this bill was trying
to do
for a follow-up follow-up thank you Mr
chairman so thank you for your support
for this bill for our community and we
understand your your position on the
funding we'll sort it out in the budget
process but we thank you for your for
that I apologize there representative uh
yes I'm going to ask everybody please
turn your your name tags to it to me
that's going to make it hard for me
because
well that's that's okay
it's not okay when the chairman gets for
sure
we have bad glasses
yes it's easier for you because after a
while I'll get it I'll have everybody's
name but not as the second meeting
representative Vale I know you can't put
it toward me I read I know
yes representative Vale for a question
thank you Mr chairman um I just have a
quick question maybe you could help me
and walk me through I'm looking at the
bill
um and it says and I'm asking you
because it says the department shall so
coming down to eight we're talking about
a potentially liable third party
um and how the treatment of that person
would be who would be a potentially
responsible or liable third party in in
terms of like an example I'm sorry can
you tell me where in the bill you're
you're at oh I'm so sorry
um I'm in the first mention is in Roman
oh I see okay and then again in four
um it's mentioned again
oh so yeah that that reference is um so
when this fund was first created as a p
faster mediation Loan Fund
um it was uh capitalized with uh 50
million dollars in in general funds or
excuse me in
um
because it was I'm sorry as a capital
appropriation and
um what it meant was we were going to be
making loans and eventually grants to
parties that needed to treat their water
but there was a concern on the part of
the legislature appropriately that if
there were parties who were responsible
for that contamination that that those
funds should in the first instance come
from those parties and so what that
provision essentially does is um if
you're going to come to the fund and
look for assistance we want to make sure
that you if you're a water system that
you've looked at you know if you have
identified and potentially responsible
party someone who caused the release and
contaminated your water supply that you
were also looking to them for assistance
that's that's what those Provisions are
about
representative harp for question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question even though you're not talking
about the appropriation you did mention
that six million dollars were allocated
before your department for different
reasons including use and then the loans
can you tell me how much of the six
million dollars was used do you know
that yes well I'm gonna I'm gonna turn
it over to the person who's managing
that money to speak to that she's a
millionaire
yes so by the end of this fiscal year we
are on track to have used every cent of
the six million dollars it's all been
appropriated to different tasks and
initiatives
um so at yeah it will all be used there
questions from anyone else uh
representative Darby
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh related to that
I'm a little confused
um it seems like this originally there
was the remediation fund which I heard a
number 50 million was funded and then 6
million was added in 2019 I think for
the um you know to help
um you know to help do the testing is
the is the 2 million basically to
continue that testing and how long do
you think that would
um would last
sure so yeah so and to be clear
um the 50 million that was initially
appropriated to this fund was
specifically and it continues to be
specifically targeted towards loans and
grants for loans for uh water systems
that are going to be treating for pfas
that money was earmarked for that and
that and it's actually all spoken for
that we're we're we're actually loan
earnings at all
that's half-spoken for so so but that
money is still available in the fund and
it's specifically earmarked for that
purpose
um the 6 million was a separate
appropriation that did not become part
of this fund it was a separate and part
appropriation that the department has
been utilizing since 2019 to do the work
that I described
so there's two things happening here
with this bill it's basically because
that money is lapsing what this bill
will do is it'll sort of renew the
directive to do that additional work and
also provide additional funding for
doing so
um so the short answer is yes it will be
to continue that work but I want to
emphasize that that work is morphing
over time right the the need that we had
back then was we still had thousands of
Wells to people who really want to have
their water sampled we still get those
requests we still have a lot of work to
do in that regard but we've made certain
a lot of progress because I think about
1.7 million of that of that 6 million
has been specifically targeted towards
analytical costs for sampling Wells so
we sampled a lot of Wells but what we're
learning you know as this so as it
morphs we have additional work to do we
have people asking questions about
um you know bio cells land application
what does that mean does that have an
impact on food supply or on soil quality
what about just areas where we know
there's been aerial deposition of pfas
what is the soil quality like we've got
a lot of work to do with regard to that
and then biota so people say well is it
safe to eat fish is it safe to eat farm
products and things like that so there's
a variety of things we don't
every time we get new data back from a
particular area or particular media that
points towards new work that we need to
do it's not really possible to
um
you know prognosticate exactly where
that money will go because we're
basically following the data we get if
we get into a neighborhood where we
didn't realize it and we suddenly
realized we have a lot of pfas
contamination drinking water a lot of
that money will go towards evaluating
that neighborhood or that Community if
we find a problem with soil or biota we
will go down that road so it's really
about reacting to the data based on the
science based on what we get as we do
this work
thank you follow up for a follow-up very
briefly
um so I in um 2019 you had six million
that lasted four years which is 1.5 per
year this you know we have a biannual
budget biennium budget and it's only 2
million so do you have enough
well and it's hard to say because I mean
I think that this would certainly put us
in a position to do this work for for a
company for the biennium I believe
um it's hard to say what what we don't
know right it's hard to say what we'll
learn but at this point
um we think this would be a a pretty
robust uh and an effective approach to
the to the
to the work that we need to do and the
challenges that we have
thanks
are there any other questions from
seeing none
Mr graze I mean representing New
Hampshire Municipal Association
for two minutes
thank you Mr chair so Nate Grace for the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
we support this bill
certainly if the committee considers
increasing the amount of funding that
would be allocated as part of this we
would support that as well it seems like
some committee members may have been
suggesting that
realistically this is the next step
forward in dealing with the pfas issue
in our state this has been a
long-running issue
uh effectively as as Mr rims to
described Des has been identifying
sources of contamination and it needs
flexibility to uh
look at those test those and figure out
what the next steps are because this is
brand new for all of us
um and the modifications to the uh the
pfas fund and the scope of that fund
will certainly enable them to do so we
know this is an incredibly expensive
problem
um it really we at the municipal level
are running hand in hand with Des on
this because as the es has identified
new and additional sources of
contamination and figured out how
exactly the best approaches are to deal
with that we at the municipal levels off
have also been responding
um particularly in the water and
wastewater area to try to make sure that
um we're we're doing everything we can
to work hand in hand with the state and
dealing with this incredible uh problem
so we support this bill and I'm happy to
take any questions that the committee
any questions for members of the
committee
Mr Vogel
Loom is he the Loon alone
preservation committee and uh and
we want to have two of these files one
for each Direction okay and then also we
need to reference a report like you have
a problem okay is this for the record
um I'll just pass it around and then
and please uh get it just give it back
we only have one of those
it'll go into the record
and
this well pass this into that direction
so uh good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Harry Vogel I'm the senior
biologist and executive director of The
Loon preservation committee I also sit
on on the Environmental Policy Committee
of New Hampshire Audubon and I'm
representing that organization as well
today
we support House Bill 212 to increase
testing and investigation of pfas in New
Hampshire wildlife many contaminants
including pfas are known to increase in
animals as you go up aquatic food webs
and that is a process known as
biomagnification and also accumulate in
long-lived animals over time a process
known as bioaccumulation so long-lived
animals at the top of aquatic food webs
and that includes fish loons Osprey
Eagles mink
otters and humans would be expected to
be among those most at risk for these
contaminants and therefore we strongly
support systematic testing for pfas and
one or more of those species
a well-studied example of the power of
biomagnification and bioaccumulation is
Mercury and Mercury can reach
concentrations over a million times
higher in fish in a Mercury contaminated
Lake than in the water of that Lake a
New Hampshire Statewide fish consumption
advisory is a result of Mercury's
ability to biomagnify and bioaccumulate
in wildlife and people
balloon preservation committee has been
testing in viable loon eggs collected
from failed nests for pfas in a broad
range of other contaminants since 2008.
LPC has tested 87 loon eggs from 28
lakes in New Hampshire for pfas and
those eggs were collected between 1993
and 2021. our sampling has been limited
due to the expense of testing and it
represents only 13 percent of Leon lakes
in the state however even in that small
sample we have found concerning levels
of pfas and other contaminants in our
stage Lakes
we found that over 37 percent of loon
eggs tested from Lakes across the state
other than Squam Lake exceeded levels of
pfos which is just a type of pfas known
to cause negative health or reproductive
effects in other bird species on Squam
Lake which has been more intensively
studied because it has experienced
unprecedented declines in survival and
breeding success of loons 61 percent of
the eggs that we tested exceeded this
level of concern
eggs collected from Canopy Lake and
Windham Arlington Mill Reservoir in
Salem and Lake Winnipesaukee had pfos
levels that were more than six times the
levels known to cause effects on
Survival or reproductive success of
other birds
follow-up investigations by the
Department of Environmental Services on
Canopy Lake and Arlington Mill Reservoir
resulted in a fish consumption advisory
for Canopy Lake and we feel that that
advisory demonstrates the importance of
monitoring pfas in these high trophic
level Wildlife to safeguard human health
and safety
we are concerned that many other New
Hampshire lakes May Harbor levels of
pfas and other contaminants that may
pose a risk to human and Wildlife health
to our knowledge LPC is the only
organization that is systematically
testing for pfas in a wide range of
other contaminants that are known to
biomagnify and bioaccumulate in wildlife
in New Hampshire
we do this work because loons are a
threatened species in New Hampshire and
and the population is far below uh
historical levels of of the population
for New Hampshire and that is despite
lpc's intensive management of the
population and research to investigate
contaminants and other challenges to
loons
lpc's capacity to carry out
comprehensive contaminants testing of
inviable lunex is limited and based on
the results of our testing to date we
believe that a rigorous and long-term
monitoring effort needs to be conducted
by the state
LPC submitted a report on our work to
measure contaminants and loon eggs to
Department of Environmental Services and
the fish and game department in November
of of 2021 and Mr chairman that is a
report that I had submitted to you
and in that report LPC called for
funding of a state agency program to
investigate and monitor bioaccumulative
contaminants including pfas pcbs and
other contaminants in fish or other
Wildlife so we fully support HP 212 and
its mandate for Des to Monitor and
investigate pfas in New Hampshire and in
fact we believe that monitoring should
be expanded to other Legacy and emerging
contaminants as well and that is the end
of my testimony but I would be happy to
answer any questions
foreign
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
okay uh Boyd uh Smith
New Hampshire
wow WWE
WWA yeah that's it I'll explain myself
thank you thank you chairman thanks
committee my name is Boyd Smith I'm with
New Hampshire Waterworks Association
we're a Statewide organization that
advocates for and works with our public
drinking water sector
so pfas is a a Statewide pervasive and
persistent problem I think we all know
that you've heard from prior testimony
how broad that is while our Focus has
been on water it's it's in waste water
it's in biosolids it's in soil it's
basically everywhere
um and the decisions that our
Association members make were they're
all science-based we you know we follow
the data we use data to make decisions
that have large impact and have large
costs if you're talking about treating a
contaminant for many many years these
are multi-million dollar projects as I'm
as I'm sure that you all know and we're
also committed to Public Health and
while I'm new to this Association about
three years anniversary now I've heard
from universally from everybody in the
water operator water treatment sector
that this is a product that people put
in their mouths so I've never worked
with such a
a broad number that are people that are
consistently so Mission focused towards
public service and public good and it's
just an amazing sector
and I say that just so to give you a
little bit of context of you know where
I'm coming from and why I'm here
so we do support this bill this idea of
monitoring and testing to get our hands
on a scope of the problem is critical
New Hampshire we're really facing a pfos
crisis this is not going to go away
anytime soon but the initial steps of
determining the extent of the problem
are absolutely critical to coming up
with a feasible solution
so I would like to just you know wrap up
reiterate we support the bill this
continues work that DS has done
incredibly well and we'll I'm sure we'll
do uh you know incredibly well into the
future you know plugging them and I've
worked with them since the 80s on one
side of the table the other I've got to
be really proud of these folks they do
amazing work for our people so that's it
from me happy to take any questions if
so any questions uh
seeing none thank you very much thank
I
[Music]
have no I do not I have no additional
pink cards
uh seeing that
that is testimony will be closed and
unless okay I have no digital pink cards
so close the test close the hearing and
the next we'll start the next hearing uh
so
started on
House Bill 276 establishing the
cyanobacteria mitigation loan litigation
Loan Fund uh
thank you very much Mr chairman for the
record my name is representative
Rosemary rung from Hillsboro 12 which is
the town of Merrimack
I also left you my written testimony at
your place after the last hearing but a
serious and growing threat to the
Granite State to our health is the
increased occurrence of cyanobacteria
blooms in our lakes and rivers
multiple scientific Studies have linked
bmaa which is a component in some
cyanotoxins
to numerous neurological diseases
including ALS and Alzheimer's
cyanotoxins also cause acute ailments
impacting the skin and digestive tracts
and can be fatal to pets and children in
the last few years alone hundreds of
recreational days on New Hampshire Lakes
were under Des Health advisories due to
high cyanobacteria accounts
to address these blooms individual
Watershed and Lake Associations and
municipalities have taken it upon
themselves to finance and prepare their
own watershed management plans which are
research-based data-driven
professionally prepared reports which
analyze the Dynamics of a water body and
identify sources of
phosphorus and nitrogen that can trigger
blooms watershed management plans also
identify how to mitigate these concerns
and
which often recommend projects such as
Wetlands restoration Road redesign
Culvert construction and septic system
replacement among others
unfortunately the cost of these plans
and the projects they identify take many
years of fundraising and requires the
preparation and passage of Town Warren
articles
Federal monies administered by the state
of New Hampshire are extremely
competitive and don't adequately cover
the costs which often causes delays of
needed projects
HB 276 would allow New Hampshire
Municipal Water Systems to also apply
for loans 37 of these systems use
surface water as their water supply
as experienced last year Some Water
Systems suffered cyanobacterial blooms
and there is a growing need for them to
have the capability to quickly respond
and treat toxins entering their system
the threat to our environment health and
economy caused by cyanobacteria blooms
is already recognized as a significant
problem for our state last year this
committee recommended for passes
passage HB 1066 to direct the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services to prepare a plan to prevent
the increase in eventual control of
cyanobacteria blooms and although this
plan will not be completed until
November it will undoubtedly require the
expenditure of funds to implement
mitigation efforts HB 276 will enable a
funding source to be available to
provide access to funds
expeditiously and with the oversight and
accountability provided by Des
in the last few days I've heard from
many people I'm sure you have too and
one person that sent me a message is an
environmental biologist called Rick
vanderpol and I'm sure many of you know
him he comes to this committee often and
he sent me a list of of some of the
issues some it may just be word choice
that he wanted addressed and and I have
a lot of respect for Mr vanderpol's
expertise as well as our own DS
commissioner commissioner Scott who
raised the concern about the ability of
watershed
associations to be able to apply for
funding and so what I would like this
committee to consider as it deliberates
and learns more about this bill is the
possibility of having a subcommittee to
address the concerns raised by the
commissioner and also other concerns
that have come up
um you know this this is a lot of money
but it's an extreme extremely important
topic that we have to address in the
state
I re refer to cyanobacteria as the
biggest threat to New Hampshire that
nobody knows about and unless you've had
first-hand experience with a bloom you
cannot understand the
um the risk the fear of of coming in
contact with it I personally know of
people whose dogs have died after going
into a lake that was suffering from a
bloom so this definitely requires our
attention I I'm very grateful that the
committee passed 1066 last year but we
aren't going to be able to address this
without funding it and so I want to make
sure that a version of 276 that does
apply for funding but does address
concerns that people have is something
that we can get through this year and
with that I am very happy to take any
questions
any members of the committee have
questioned
representative Darby
representative wrong do you know if
someone's going to be testifying about
what the
um what the plan or how the funding
would be uh used since there's there's a
number of factors that go into the
um you know the mitigation plans
yes thank you for for your question one
of the issues that
um Mr vanderpol raised was how do we
qualify
the watershed management plans and there
are there is EPA standards for these
plans so I I think a subcommittee could
look at incorporating that requirement
in the plan
um also even to have funding for
watershed management plans because the
the costs can be upwards of a hundred
thousand dollars and so a lot of these
small Lake Associations it's it's
incredible for them they I mean how many
bake sales does it take to raise a
hundred thousand dollars
um so we we may want to be incorporate
that into the plan but if it is an EPA
approved plan and they're professionally
done
um I was involved in the preparation of
a watershed management plan a couple
years ago and the projects they identify
are really driven on data that's
collected
very research that goes into the impact
that the data may have on a water body
so I'm very confident that Des has the
expertise to be able to assess any of
these loan applications and determine if
that project is going to is is needed if
it's
um if it and if it's going to
demonstrate some mitigation of
phosphorus or nitrogen loading in the
lake
I hope I answered your question okay
thank you
I will say to the committee there is
someone on the list of speakers from Des
uh represent representative Donnelly
our question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this may be a
question that
is related back to Des
um I read an article that talked about
the um acreage burning from the west and
we all remember last year how much that
smoke carried over and that the ash from
has anyone anyone done any testing from
the ash that has been uh done the ash
from all the forest fires from the West
that kids come across our great lakes
and they have contributed a lot of these
algae blooms to some of that Ash has any
testing been done or any research done
from
the forest fires that have been done
thank you for the question I'm not aware
of any but that would be a point well
we've seen and and I'm sure
um the experts from DS could comment
more about this but
um the biggest trigger from my
experience with
cyanobacteria blooms is that the
temperature of the water is changing our
profile is changing in fact I believe
there's still open areas of Lake
Winnipesaukee now
um and so ice in is happening later and
as ice out is happening earlier and the
Dynamics of that change in our climate
and the change in in the the the the
temperature of the water is causing
striations that enable
cyanobacteria to flourish
um and so even the even if nitrogen and
phosphorus loading haven't changed over
the course of the last several decades
um because the temperature has we have
to modify those other variables so if so
in other words if if there were no
temperature changes in our Lakes
that maybe the the current runoff of
nitrogen and phosphorus may not have
been a trigger but because of the warmer
temperatures now it is
but any so what we have to do is be able
to control what is in our power to
control and
for instance even the the forest fires
down that's something we can't control
so it might require us to be more
diligent in what we are controlling
that's going into the lake and and
typically the biggest General factor is
runoff
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
David Niels
from
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Ted deers I am the
assistant director of The Water Division
at the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services I am accompanied
here by Dave Niels who are see who is
our senior biologist for the Department
I'm going to kick us off and then turn
it right over to Dave uh because he's
the scientist
um but if there's questions about uh
sort of more policy or how we do things
at DES or budgetary types of stuff then
I will be here to be able to answer
those kinds of questions
so uh cyanobacteria is a huge issue I
think representative brung did a
fantastic job of introducing sort of the
whole issue
um Dave is going to talk a little bit
more about the issue itself sort of what
we know about cyanobacteria and about
the commission or the committee and the
plan the Des is currently writing
regarding cyanobacteria and and the plan
that we're going to use to be able to
guide our efforts moving forward
it is a potentially expensive issue and
we're not taking a necessarily a
position on this particular Bill given
that it is a budget year and our budget
has not yet been presented
um so we're not going to necessarily
take a position but just to outline some
of the issues related to cyanobacteria
and really be here for you all uh to be
able to provide input to provide
information as you need it in order to
make use your important decisions so
with that I'm going to turn it right
over to Dave and he can take it from
there
foreign
thanks Ted good morning committee uh
many Chairman's although thank you again
for the opportunity to testify again my
name is David Niels I'm the chief
aquatic biologist at DES and um I'd like
to talk just a little bit about
cyanobacteria give you a little bit of
background on on how they're sort of
presenting themselves in our Lake and
they are a natural part of the lake
ecosystem
many of you that may be familiar with
them would recognize them as a green
scum that forms on the top of a water
body or sometimes it presents itself as
coloring the entire water body green
over the past five years are lakes and
ponds across the state of New Hampshire
continue to exhibit many cyanobacterial
blooms and in fact we've had 34
advisories on average over the past five
years and that usually represents about
seven to eight hundred recreational days
combined in loss of recreational use of
our lakes or water bodies so it it is of
a large impact on our water bodies so
that we're talking about recreational
impacts only
the average length of advisory is about
25 days so if you see an advisory posted
on a water body
it's not something like fecal bacteria
that may last a couple of days it lasts
much longer
this past year we had 46 advisories on
our lakes and ponds and over 50 alerts
so an alert is a little bit less than
advisory I know that being becomes
confusing but cyanobacteria are very
um they they move very quickly so it's
oftentimes difficult to issue a formal
advisory when they present themselves as
a very quick Bloom and then they move
around the lake by wind driven
activities so we've we've instituted
this alert
as a way to quickly get the word out to
recreational users around the water body
as representative run talked about the
health risks of cyanobacteria come from
the cyanotoxins that they produce
there's many different cyanotoxins and
they present themselves in many
different forms the toxins are numerous
as I mentioned they impact not only our
recreational water supplies but also our
Drinking Water Supplies which is very
very important
lastly they can impact agricultural uses
in the way of watering
watering animals and also for the crops
that that we rely on so based on our
experiences what we know blooms are
generally related to excessive nutrient
loads into the water body
I sort of sort of think about it in a
tea kettle fashion so if you think about
what a plant needs to grow they need
light they need nutrients and they need
temperature so as representative rung
spoke about you put all those things in
a in a tea kettle and let them sort of
swirl around for a while you can end up
with a cyanobacteria bloom things that
present those nutrients are things like
storm water I'm sure most people know
what storm water is but it's an ongoing
problem that's related to development
and runoff
lastly nutrients are can be added to
Lake through historical
processes that occur in the bottom of
the lake so as we get warmer and warmer
temperatures the amount of oxygen on the
bottom of our Lake decreases and that
can release nutrients from historical
activities so that's something that we
see pretty frequently
several Lakes Bloom every year and we
know which are sort of our recurring
lakes that have cyanobacteria blooms but
what we're finding every year is that
more and more Lakes Bloom that we are
not aware of we're not sure if that's
exactly a result of additional
cyanobacteria blooms and the problems
that they present but we also have
people becoming more and more aware of
the cyanobacteria blooms that are out
there so they're looking for those
most importantly and the thing that this
bill addresses we currently have little
opportunity to implement fixes to sign
or bacterial blooms and that's one of
the questions that I get most frequently
in my position is people experience a
cyanobacteria bloom they're frustrated
by the fact that they can't use their
water body or in the case where it
impacts a water supply that really
impacts Public Health but what they
really want to know as a result of that
bloom is how do we fix that and right
now we don't have the resources to fix
that bloom so that's one way that this
to date the only example that we have in
recent past where we've taken a a water
body that was experienced a bloom full
circle created a watershed management
plan worked through the Community
Development process and implemented what
I call an in-lake management action was
on nipple Lake and that was done two
years ago and so far that's been very
successful
so it's important to keep that in mind
I'm happy to answer any questions about
that
also I want to bring it back to the
Statewide
cyanobacteria management plan that Des
is currently working on and the advisory
committee that goes along with it input
from the committee and Des professional
staff will result in many many
recommendations on cyanobacteria
monitoring communication research and
obviously mitigation this report will be
completed in November 2023 and we think
this bill will address many of the
concerns or many of the recommendations
that are presented in that plan
as Ted mentioned while Des has not take
an official position on this bill in
particular it in its intention addresses
many of the following needs that we feel
will be detailed in the management plan
we know that there will be a need to
mitigate of cyanobacterial blooms that's
going to without a doubt be one of the
primary recommendations in this plan it
also establishes a dedicated program at
DES but that dedicated program could be
anywhere for mitigating cyanobacterial
blooms
it also requires the the development of
watershed based plans or consideration
of watershed based plans which often
talk about control of external nutrient
sources which is critical for mitigating
cyanobacterial blooms and then lastly it
provides an opportunity to for funding
through the through loans
to mitigate cyanobacterial blooms not
just for recreational uses but for
drinking water supplies which is a very
very critical component
Des is very committed to understanding
uh cyanobacteria blooms tracking them
monitoring them the need for mitigation
is a growing concern that is existing
around the state and severity appears to
be increasing of our cyanobacteria
blooms as well
we appreciate the legislature's
continued interest in this subject and
consideration for potential actions to
mitigating cyanobacteria blooms I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
excuse me I put a as chair I think I'm
gonna I have to have to leave for
another hearing very shortly I'd like to
get my question in first then then
uh this is basically for uh
Mr deers uh well policy uh this is kind
of
on the normal you know just preface uh
is this kind of the tail end of the dog
uh in when we could we're cons we have a
1066 request a plan
that the Des is going to be creating
which will culminate in actions well
this being an action is this the tale
that's wagging the dog uh
of
I'll ask you that question great thank
you very much for the question I I think
there's a number of ways to look at this
one of the things that Dave just um you
know focused on is that this isn't a new
issue cyanobacteria is not a new issue
we've been dealing with it we've been
writing management plans we've been you
know funding management plans and
actions on watersheds to reduce
nutrients for 20 years so so there are
elements of the plan which will come out
this 1066 plan which are known there are
elements which are being brainstormed
right now by the very uh creative and
and knowledgeable people both within our
own staff as well as the the members of
a really outstanding advisory committee
um that I think is is really it's a
remarkable assemblage of people that are
are really contributing to this so I
think that what you're going to see out
of the plan at the end of it is that
there are some uh resource needs that
are identified that this potentially
would help to fill
there are also going to be a number of
different policies maybe even some
statutory stuff there's going to be
programmatic things there's going to be
how do you know how do citizens become
involved with citizen science there's
gonna be a lot of different aspects of
that come out of this so I don't think
that that this bill is necessarily
um you know it's not necessarily in
front of the wagon here
um it really is just I think one element
that is likely to be part of that future
uh what we don't know exactly what's
going to look like because we haven't
written it yet so to that extent I think
we do know that there will be resources
needed to implement that plan what those
resources look like will probably
include mitigation as well as any other
a number of different other science
practice policies procedures all those
for another question yes
yes
many of these
uh
loans funds funds have an oversight
committee uh I don't see that in here is
that uh
would that be necessary
um good question I think that's
certainly up to the committee we have
any number of different loan programs
that don't
have an advisory committee we have some
that do it
um you know it really depends on how
this uh how the Beast gets created so it
could have that
um we certainly have a lot of experience
uh with developing Grant criteria which
are then you know judged by uh either
staff or or some other group that looks
at that that criteria and scores those
proposals we have a long history of
doing that both
with input from the outside and and and
or or with staff experience and then uh
for example the the srf grants it's a
good example of a of a program that does
a whole Grant solicitation there's
there's readily published criteria for
what they what where they would score
the the staff get together they score
their proposals
and then they release it to the public
so the public has a comment has an
opportunity to comment and say oh you
you missed you missed part of my prison
you messed my part of my proposal or or
did you think about this or or maybe you
didn't give this quite enough points
um so there's lots of ways to set up a
system whereby you have both input as
well as firm criteria that help you come
up with really good proposals
thank you all going to church turn the
gavel over first I'll recognize
representative Vale and then turn the
gavel also turn the gavel over to the
vice chair Vice chair harp
thank you very much thanks we'll see you
later
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um actually I think this is more I'm not
sure who this is for either you or
whether it's biology or policy but I
just wanted to know how cyanobacteria
affects like a Municipal Water Supply
I'm from Nashua full disclosure from a
city and we have a reservoir and an
extensive system that includes ponding
and Wells and so that's my question
okay I'll do the best I can to answer
that so um I think cyanobacteria have
the opportunity to impact a water supply
pretty severely it would depend on the
severity of the bloom obviously
most Water Supplies are not a water
supply expert but they have the ability
to do some treatment of the water supply
and most you know they have filtration
they have ozonation UV and some of those
practices can remove the cyanobacteria
themselves the the challenge becomes
when a bloom is very very severe
the cyanobacteria
themselves may be filtered out but the
toxins that they produce are very
difficult to treat
so in a very severe Bloom you would have
a situation where the population of
cyanobacteria are continually
reproducing and the as they die off they
release the the cyanotoxins into the
water body and they would be free and
available so I'm not quite sure how
effective at all the treatments would be
in removing those but it certainly can
be problematic and you really don't need
to do a lot of Googling to uh to find
out where that was problematic you can
out in Toledo Ohio their entire water
system was shut down for a period of
weeks because of a very severe
thank you so much for the answer
any other questions from the
representatives
representative
thank you for uh thank you Mr Vice chair
and thank you for taking my question
um you mentioned the uh the
sorry the plan
um the res the resource management plan
that was executed
can you
um I'm trying to understand
um the the
pieces that basically where the funding
goes in terms of the various components
that factor into these blooms because
you know as I've as I've read lots and
lots and lots of emails
um the uh you know there's there's many
factors that contribute and so it it's
not it doesn't seem like it's just a
turnkey solution so I'm trying to
understand the flow of funds to all the
pieces
Ted can fill in when you talk about
plans I'm going to assume that you mean
Watershed based plants okay so Watershed
based plans can be used for a variety of
factors and one of the the things that
we're seeing more and more is watershed
based plans are being used to address
cyanobacterial blooms
those plans uh include a whole variety
of different things they usually start
with a with some background research and
uh and Community Development so you have
to build sort of a coalition of people
behind those one of the big parts of a
cyanobacteria or I'm sorry Watershed
based plan includes a technical
investigation of the lake to understand
the nutrient sources and the nutrient
loading factors and that's that's more
of a scientific process so that's one
part of many that the funding goes to
the second part is really the
implementation of restoration activities
and that's sort of what this bill in
particular would address there's also
Community sort of Outreach and education
components of a watershed based plan
that are really critical so that's sort
of where those funding sources go
yeah
just to add on to that is that you know
there are a number of different factors
which cause a cyanobacteria bloom and so
understanding those and they're they're
all kind of Lake specific
um the the differences between our Lakes
you may not see it from the from the
surface
but our Lakes are very different whether
they're shallow or deep Lakes do they
stratify do they not stratify what's the
turnover rate that they have on an
annual basis so one of the things that's
done are these Lake diagnostic studies
that look very carefully at Lakes I also
just want to point out because the good
Folks at the Rivers Council would um
would beat me about The Head and
Shoulders if I don't is that it is also
possible to have cyanobacteria blooms on
rivers and in fact that did happen last
year so this isn't just a lake specific
thing you see you see it more on lakes
because they're sort of as they've
suggested they're more of that tea
kettle
but but there can be lots of sources
they can be internal sources historic
you know nippo I think the the loading
that was in the bottom of the lake
really relates back to deforestation
back in the 1800s that sits in the
bottom of the lake and then you know
Rises when when uh the the dissolved
oxygen is so low there are other places
where there's lots of active sources of
nutrients all of that has to get
addressed to that specific Lake that's
why these kinds of watershed based plans
are so important is because they're
customized to the particulars of that
particular body of water of what would
be causing the problem there and how you
follow up
thank you for the follow-up
let me try to be a little more specific
with my question
um and obviously I'm very naive on this
but you know factors that can contribute
are failing septic systems poor
landscape practices
dirt roads I've read and write off from
dirt roads so
um ultimately that to fix those those
involve a lot of private parties and a
wide variety of different sort of owners
of those properties how does a how does
a fund sort of engage all those private
parties to sort of collaborate on the
solution yeah
yeah that's a that is the trick uh and
that that's why we have professional
staff that work with communities to try
to build the coalitions to do exactly
that
there are some solutions which are you
know sort of municipal or you know
whoever owns a Lake Association or Golf
Course or you know other other sorts of
you know sort of larger entities there
are also you know the the death by a
thousand paper cuts issues and and so it
really does require a coalition this is
not a regulatory approach
this is an approach in which you take a
science-based data-driven approach that
comes up with solutions that can be
implemented at a local scale by those
folks who have the ability to implement
them so if it's a dirt road then you
might be working with the municipality
to be able to address the runoff from
that dirt road if it's a set of mean if
it's a set of of homes or septic systems
we have actually dealt with groups of of
homeowners in developments that no they
have septic system issues and try to
address that there are other storm water
Landscaping you'll probably hear from
New Hampshire Lakes Association they
have programs that are oriented
specifically on Lakefront homeowners to
talk to them about about their practices
on their particular bodies of water or
their particular land adjacent to the
water all of that has to kind of come
together
over time so it isn't just just hey
point at somebody it's their fault
you know this is uh this is we have met
the enemy and they is US kind of a of of
problem which requires that kind of
Coalition building which is a big part
of how you implement Watershed based
plants
thank you
any other questions representative
McHugh
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Deuce for coming to talk to
us about cyanobacteria nobody likes
green ponds come on their Lakes
um can we talk a little bit about the
the funding and the 25 million dollars
for a second
um I see that the bill says and your
testimony says that up to a million
dollars of this money can be used
annually to support the projects and
meet the criteria outlined in the bill
what about the other 24 million how does
that how does that work
mechanically when does that when does
that money get used so I I think that
that would still need to be figured out
um but my understanding is that what we
would do is that would sit in uh trust
essentially non-lapsing account that
would then be accessed over time and
they would be generate overtime or
repayment account some of it would be
used for loan forgiveness some of it for
Grants and then some of it would be loan
would be you know repaid so this would
be a self-sustaining fund um after that
initial contribution that's that's the
way I think it as I understand the the
bill that it's set up to do that it's
not not unlike
um some of the other funds that that we
administer such as the groundwater trust
such as mtbe you know there are some of
those that we uh administer that are
falling to that same kind of um genre
for the question thank you Mr chairman
so thanks will I guess we'll leave the
financial the bonding and the 30-year
credit access and all that to the
finance committee that this will go to
because I don't quite understand it here
admittedly that's why I'm not in the
finance committee right um that's what
we'll bring our our CFO also because I
don't understand that either so and I
understand that um
DES isn't taking a position on on the
bill anyhow but thank you for the
education on the cyanobacteria can you
help us at least understand how Des
prioritizes this issue amongst the
Myriad of other issues can you at least
prioritize it on us the this money or
this issue for the committee sure to be
on a scale of one to ten is it a top you
know number one priority or number 10
priority or something give us reasonable
education uh this is definitely a top 10
issue I think
um and and it comes back to this is an
indicator cyanobacteria is an indicator
of other things going on and and so when
you think about all of the Myriad ways
in which we're trying to improve water
quality whether it be pfas or or you
know other kinds of issues Arsenic and
drinking water when we look at when we
look at the issues related to storm
water and and especially our surface
water quality
90 percent
uh well let me put it let me put it what
back up a step New Hampshire has
excellent water quality
our surface waters have excellent water
quality let's put that out there
compared to a lot of other places in the
world we have really good water quality
except where we don't
and the places where we don't are 90
related to surface water runoff or other
non-point sources of contamination so I
just want to put that into context that
yes we're this is a lovely State we are
so fortunate to live in a place that is
has a healthy environment overall
but we do have the issues and when these
kinds of issues show up they're largely
related to the same kinds of things that
cause cyanobacteria to bloom so that's
why in the context of sort of water writ
large it's a relatively important issue
and there's a lot we don't know about
cyanobacteria and so as we learn more
and as we become more aware of it it's
one of those things where we start to
recognize that it's it may be more
dangerous or important than we thought
finally I will say that we've also
received Federal funding our drinking
water programs are now receiving we
think it's going to be around 10 million
dollars a year to address emerging
contaminants
those emerging contaminants include pfas
and some of those other things like pfas
but it also includes cyanobacteria the
federal government has now recognized
the importance of cyanobacteria related
to drinking water so I think does that
help to put it in context of sort of at
least from a water perspective
thank you is the federal funding enough
that you don't need this so one of the
challenges that the federal funding is
that it is exclusively to water supply
so it doesn't address Recreation it
doesn't address recreational impacts to
um to lakes and ponds it only addresses
that so that's 34 37 whatever you said
uh representative wrong said uh that
only affects those particular bodies of
water out of the Thousand
um lakes and ponds that we have in the
17 000 miles of rivers and streams we
have in the state
thank you so it's the top 10 issue for
the year I think so thank you
I have a question from Mr Nails
um you mentioned the Nichols Lake can
you do you know how large the lake is
and how much you spent on that
great thank you for your question
um nipple Lake well you had to ask me
how large it is I don't know the acreage
of the top of my head I would say
um it's a medium-sized medium to small
size Lake
um I'm trying to think something that
would
um you would find relevant but you know
probably on the order of 50 acres so
I'll put it at that and I do have some
numbers here just because I think nippo
is a really good example for people to
understand
a watershed based plan development costs
about a hundred thousand dollars
so that's about what was spent on nipple
league for development of the plan
there were several things that needed to
go into sort of implementing sort of
external nutrient controls on that water
body before we could even address the
the internal control and and they spent
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars controlling external nutrient
sources this is from sources like roads
so that was the big one we found one
sort of Smoking Gun it was a it was a
dirt road that was poorly drained and it
was a lot of sediment was running into
the lake
the last part of the project was really
the internal in Lake management which I
mentioned which was the addition of
aluminum to the lake in total that
effort ended up costing about 350 000
and that included a whole bunch of
things before we even did the treatment
the treatment itself was about a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars and the
reason we had to spend additional monies
is that the last time we had done an
Alum treatment in the state of New
Hampshire was 1984. so there's really no
history there for us to understand the
process by which an Alum treatment could
be planned executed and permitted so
thank you any other Representatives have
questions
if
yes yeah that's a great question thank
you very much for that question
as Ted mentioned every lake is different
so we we work through the process of
understanding what the nutrient sources
are for every individual Lake for lakes
that have
a large population around it a lot of
development septic systems certainly
play a large portion into the nutrient
loading component for nippo Lake which
doesn't isn't heavily developed
the loading from septic systems I was
gonna I'm gonna estimate was around 20
so it was you know it wasn't a large
part of the contribution to nutrient
loads whereas the internal load was well
it can be from a variety of sources but
it's typically historic sources
activities that occurred on the
landscape in the past and the release of
the nutrients from the internal
components from the internal sediment is
a result of low oxygen on the bottom of
the water body so as representative rung
mentioned
as we progress through what we like to
refer to as climate change our water
bodies tend to get warmer warmer water
holds less oxygen so it's more likely
that those water bodies that experience
low dissolved oxygen will be
experiencing for a longer period of time
on the bottom and there'll be more of
those water bodies that have that
experience
and I have the representative questions
I don't see any thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
it is a normal procedure to alternate
between those in favor and those who
oppose the bill I have 11 pink cards
here maybe more and they're all in favor
is there anyone here that didn't fill a
seeing non-hearing none in heaven no
pink cards uh for the against I'll go
through those in favor I'd just ask you
to be judicious in your testimony if
you're repeating what somebody else said
but love to have you testify
so next is uh natch graze New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair Nate Grace for the
municipal Association we support this
bill and just very briefly I think that
Des covered everything
um that I would have had to say which is
that this is clearly a concern for
Public Water Supplies as well as
recreational and economic activities of
which municipalities are deeply
concerned and so we are in support of
this bill I'm happy to take any
questions that anyone may have any
questions for Mr Grays yes Mr Darby
thank you for uh Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um can you comment on what you think the
um down the future tax implications
could be on the reduction of the tax
base if the you know if the recreational
value diminishes in um has have you
received that uh feedback from Matt from
any of the municipalities you support or
represents so I don't have any
particular data on that but as everyone
in this room knows a number of
municipalities rely heavily on tourism
to drive a large part of their uh their
tax base and you know everything from
rentals to to shops and uh and that
obviously goes into what the property
values are
um which is the basis for our tax system
and a large part of that uh for a number
of municipalities is because they're
along lakes and lakes that are you for
recreational activities like Lake
Winnipesaukee and obviously if it
becomes the case that that that water
body or other large water bodies that
are recreational hubs are no longer
useful for a portion of the year because
of cyanobacteria contamination that's
going to be a serious problem for the
tax base and the valuation of those
properties
thank you
any other questions from Mr grays
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next I have Warren Emily of Lake
winnipocket
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee it's an honor to be here to
speak
my name is Warren Emily I live in
Concord
but I own a seasonal camp on lake
winnipockets in Webster
and I wish to speak about our experience
on that Lake
I'd like to tell you a story about Lake
winnipocket
this is a relatively small Lake 240
acres
it's got a perimeter of three miles it's
got an average depth of 12 feet
it has really no active inflow or
outflow and so it sits there like the
old Glacier that it used to be fed by
some spring water and perhaps some rain
certainly
but over the years in fact 27 years in a
row Our Lake Association has been very
diligent in testing the water through
the Des
vlap program volunteer Lake Assessment
program
uh and that of course looks for not only
bacteria and invasive species but tests
the quality of the water with regard to
phosphorus and runoff and many other
things to assess the clarity of the lake
and we have remained an oligotrophic
Lake which is the highest quality of
water that is possible
every year at our Lake Association
meeting we go over the elements how do
you preserve the quality of this Lake
not only for our property values but for
all the safety of the people who come to
visit the lake and want to swim
it doesn't have a lot of large boat
activity it's got lots of kayaks and
canoes
[Music]
and that smaller boats swimming some
fishing and so it's a beautiful quiet
Lake
and we were just there enjoying that
beautiful water until two years ago
and to no one's to everyone's surprise
we saw this green scum on the lake
how could this happen in our Clear Lake
which we are so diligent in surveying
and it wasn't just one location it was
several we really didn't know much about
cyanobacteria except that we knew that
it had potential toxicity
and so we got a cyanobacteria alert we
stayed out of the water for a couple of
weeks we didn't know whether it was
toxic or not really changed our life for
that summer
fortunately for us the cyanobacteria
blooms disappeared no one no animals
nothing that we know of was affected by
the toxicity
but that was a real heads up for us why
should our small Lake
be subject to cyanobacteria and we're
still learning more about this
when the discussion came up well what
are we going to do if we can't clear
this we said well we're going to have to
do something and we looked at our budget
ladies and gentlemen the budget as has
been alluded to for our Lake Association
is minuscule you're hearing numbers like
hundreds of thousands of dollars
we go to four figures at most and that's
pretty typical I think for a small Lake
Our Lake would be devastated if we had a
a cyanobacteria infestation that really
didn't clear on its own
to talk to the board of Selectmen at the
town of Webster would be a real exercise
and I don't know what but I'm not sure
that that would really get us anywhere
near the amount of money that we would
need
so to make to to be very succinct about
it
establishing a fund of this nature and I
think I can speak for many of the
smaller lakes in this state would be a
wonderful opportunity for us to at least
apply
for some financial help
to to mitigate the consequences of
cyanobacteria
moreover I think it's it sends a
reputation of responsibility
for the State of New Hampshire which
could really go out beyond our state
boundaries about how responsible we feel
we should be about the quality of our
Lake
and don't ever doubt that that's
important in Massachusetts and Vermont
and New York and every place else that
comes to visit us in the summertime it
shows a real sense of responsibility and
that's why
I'm happy to answer any questions anyone
representative Harvey boleya thank you
very much for your testimony
um I was wondering if you have ever
heard of the cyanotoxin monitoring
equipment and training Grant
that
new ant New Hampshire Des uh
administers to which helps with this
sort of thing thank you
I can't speak excuse me specifically to
that particular one I do know that there
are
ways to analyze the cyanobacteria and
analyze its toxicity
and that's nice they can come out and
test to see if the stuff is really
poisonous or not
um but by the time that happens you've
already had your Bloom and blooms can
change over time the biology these
blooms were still working out I look at
that as a way to document the relative
safety levels of going into the water
which is nice to know but it doesn't
really address the um the existence of
this particular organism in the water
uh I can't speak as a scientist at DES
but I do know those those testing
representative wolf
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um this bill is
um called a Loan Fund for
cyanobacteria mitigation investigation
Etc
it also specifies that it may go to
Lakes association's non-profits Etc
loan to me means repayment now maybe it
should be renamed a grant program but
what is the protection for the state on
getting the loan repaid
I don't think that I'm in a position to
answer that question I appreciate your
question
I look at this as the president of my
local Lake Association
as an opportunity to apply for money to
help mitigate the spread and the
potential worsening of this in our Lake
and that our lake is just a prototype
I'll be frank with you the Lake
winnipocket Conservation Association has
no way to repay a loan of this type
but this is not our Lake we just live
there
this is the lake in the town of Webster
in the state of New Hampshire which
serves really a wider Community than the
homeowners around
and so my opinion would be it's not
going to be
imperative that the borrowers or the the
applicants for this money are have to
pay it back first of all it isn't going
to happen secondly I don't think it's
really the direction that we really want
just to follow up on your follow-up
thank you uh then it may be more
appropriate
to call it what if in reality is going
to be is a grant program
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um have you approached the town of
Webster and since municipalities can
take out the loans
um is uh would you consider going to the
town of Webster and seeing if they would
take out the loan on your behalf thank
you for the question absolutely yes
Tyler Webster has a lot invested in Lee
quarter pocket it's far and away the
greatest source of tax revenue for the
town of Webster
uh have we done so yet
not yet but you know I don't want to I
don't want to go there without getting
the facts so to speak as Joe Friday used
to say I'm really uh interested in what
this committee is going to come up with
and how this legislation is going to go
I believe that if the committee sees fit
to put some sort of a bill like this
through that's going to make the town of
Webster a lot more willing to
participate if they think they're going
to have to fund that 500 000 mitigation
on their own
they're going to say well you look you
guys live around the lake you got a lot
of money why don't you I can just hear
the discussion now I'm not sure where
I'm going with this but to say yes we
certainly will talk to the town of
Webster selectman and get them involved
and participate both emotionally and
financially
thank you
any more questions from the
representatives hearing none thank you
uh for your testimony thank you very
much
Norm Royce
Northern Lake watershed
good morning and thank you for your time
this morning my name is Norm Royce I'm
the president of the Northwood Lake
Watershed Association
our mission is to mitigate aquatic
invasive species so cyanobacteria is not
in our mission
uh in terms of fundraising we raise
about fifty thousand dollars a year we
have several different streams of
fundraising activity it's residents
around the lake uh the three towns that
border the lake we have a warrant
article on all three towns to request
funds local businesses and then state
grants through the assistance and
coordination with New Hampshire Des
we have no money in our fundraising
capability
to either communicate the risks around
cyanobacteria
what folks should be doing to help
prevent it or to manage cyanobacterial
outbreaks on Northwood Lake
historically we had not seen
cyanobacteria on Northwood Lake until
the last couple years we had an event
and then we had two events and then we
had multiple events so it seems like
each year it's becoming more and more of
a problem
we work closely with New Hampshire Des
I'm really impressed with New Hampshire
Des front line resources
but New Hampshire Des is under-resourced
and all those folks on the front line
help us they help us right away they
have great skill they show passion in
the work that they do but there's just
not enough resources to help what we do
for us from my view in Northwood Lake
watershed's View communication right now
is really key with cyanobacteria you
know lake living
um
Northwood like many lakes in New
Hampshire
historically had small old Cottages
built on postage stamp Lots those are
being purchased and torn down and
beautiful new homes are being built I
did the same I built my new home four
years ago
I had the benefit of being a member of
the Northwood Lake Watershed and
understanding my new build and the
impact that what I chose to do with my
build on the lake would impact the
quality level of the lake and things
like cyanobacteria
so people tearing down new homes
and tearing down the shoreline buffer
zone tearing up plants cutting down
trees and then putting in big beautiful
grass Lawns that they fertilize with
phosphate even though it's against the
law I'll contribute to the chemical feed
of cyanobacteria and having it grow
um you know when we experience an event
um New Hampshire DS helps us with our
communication and it would go something
like this you know we put out a notice
Northwood Lake just experienced that for
us cyanobacteria bloom for 2022.
typically it's on one of the hottest
days of the summer you know people are
excited I live on a lake we're going to
go out boating and swimming and water
skiing and our family and friends are
going to come over and we tell them stay
out of the lake until we can sample what
it is sample the severity of it and then
we'll communicate back to you as it
clears when you can get back into the
water so obviously not a very very good
one of the communication efforts that we
have as a Lake Association is we not
just tell people that we had a bloom but
we tell them what they can do to prevent
cyanobacteria blooms and again this
information comes to us through the
support of both New Hampshire des and
New Hampshire Lakes
and we asked you know have they had a
septic system inspection not just pump
your septic system make sure it's
inspected every couple of years to make
sure it's functioning properly and and
not contributing to the problem we
advise them don't fertilize your lawn
within 25 feet of the water and we
remind them that this is a law in New
Hampshire and Beyond 25 feet don't use
phosphate fertilizers and we share with
them that our local hardware store has
the right fertilizer that they could use
we remind them to responsibly prune
along the shoreline keep as many native
plants as they can we have to you know
remind them about their parking surface
areas and access areas and understand
where runoff is going on their property
and that it's not going directly into
the lake but it's being diverted
and then you know a couple other things
I think the uh the other thing that I
wanted to make sure I mentioned is
um again you know communication is key
New Hampshire Lakes they have a couple
of great programs they have this Lake
smart program that talks about lake
living and really the expectations that
all of us that live on or near Lakes
have as a responsibility
they also ran what was called the late
Congress in conjunction with New
Hampshire DES in conjunction with an
awful lot of suppliers contractors that
can help with how to live along a lake
and in that late Congress they did a
great job communicating
cyanobacteria and what it is how long
it's been around how cyanobacteria
blooms but that was to those of us that
were able to attend Lake Congress we've
got to get this word out to everybody in
New Hampshire that lives near or on a
lake and just in closing I wanted to
mention you know listening to the costs
associated with the cyanobacteria
concerns on nipple lake nippo lake is 85
Acres so I looked it up while I was
waiting to speak
Northwood lake is 653 Acres
the funds that we raise
we barely cover the milfoil mitigation
we really don't have any capability to
raise additional funds either through
town warrant articles or through the
residents in and along the lake and in
the Watershed to be able to to mitigate
if Northwood Lake was that serious as
nipple Lake that we had to go through
some of the treatments described
so that's the information I wanted to
share I think this bill is essential we
had invited congresswoman rung to our
annual meeting last year where she
shared with the residents in Northwood
the concerns about cyanobacteria we just
think it's such a significant thing in
New Hampshire and the time to address it
is now we don't want to wait a couple
years
um
and with that I'll look just close
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you everyone for your time
actually caught me sneaking out the door
uh thanks for the opportunity to get in
front of you again
um I did mention the prior testimony
that uh my name is Boyd Smith I'm with
the director of the New Hampshire Water
Works Association uh I mentioned that we
had
um that we represent the public water
drinking water sector in the state and
that totals up to a little more than 300
members many represented by
municipalities uh and others in in the
Consulting and design world
so um our takea oh prior that my prior
life though I was working at Newfound
Lake as the Director where we ran what I
think at the time was the largest
watershed management plan in the state
and it's had a great time learning about
that stuff and working with the folks so
um I just say the short short version is
we support this uh understand where
we're going to find the money is always
a question the Waters of the state
whether for drinking water or for
recreation generate
north of a billion I'm guessing more
like two billion dollars a year uh in in
Revenue so we as a state I think it's
well within our sort of moral compass
and hopefully within our budget to take
care of something that provides so much
uh to so many this one other thought on
the drinking water side is
um
public water serves roughly 54 percent
of the population
in the state so 600 something thousand
seven hundred thousand people
out of that
um
so it's like
50 percent of the total population is
served by just a handful of systems you
know most of our systems are small so
the bigger systems you mentioned in
Nashua and pennichuck and they depend
almost exclusively on surface water so
whether pulling out a canopy lake or
mass obesic the Merrimack River is is a
huge source and obviously a long-term
source for the state
this is where the cyanobacteria blooms
are showing and it's a problem that's
systemic that we have to deal with so
from a drinking water perspective taking
care of our source Waters the guys say
if you you know if you don't have it to
treat you know you don't have it
um top of that the recreational benefit
but anyway we fully support this
protecting our source Waters and I'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you questions for Mr Smith
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question did did I understand that
you in in a previous role
um or part of a Lake Association
um that uh managed that ran a watershed
management plan and if you if that's the
case can you describe how you
coordinated the funds and how you um how
you basically interacted with all the
parties
um that you needed to disperse those
funds to the private the private parties
that I mentioned in a previous question
sure I'll give that a shot and I'll try
and be succinct so um I was the director
of the Newfound Lake Region Association
uh Scott Newfound Lake and it's a
ligatrophic Class A 4500 acres and a 65
000 acre Watershed so it's about a 15 to
1 land to water ratio the funding that
we received was EPA section 319 funding
administered to the nhds Watershed
Bureau
um we came in uh initially as planning
grants which I think a lot of folks are
talking about the value of understanding
uh your system and what what the issues
are and how you might manage them uh we
manage the grant we project Managed IT
and we're like the local face on the you
know the position on the ground there's
basically five towns surrounding
Newfound that are on the waterfront so
five different basically small New
Hampshire towns and then passed a large
amount of money through to
subcontractors typically between uh
sorry um
60 and 70 percent anyway or more of the
grant funds went to subs and we did
things like land use analysis a very
detailed GIS mapping
demographics growth percentages of land
cover
um
a lot of water quality monitoring near
shore and deeper water to look at Trends
we saw some of these Trends now this
data is getting on you know five or
seven years old but we saw some of these
Trends you're hearing about and we
started rolling into implementation
which is the way the EPA Pro program is
set up you have to have a plan but then
you've got to implement on that plan so
it's sort of a sequential thing and the
main things you got to deal with are
land use as you've heard it's it's
non-point source pollution so there's a
variety of sources dirt roads you know
are big right and everybody's got dirt
roads waterfront property how you manage
your your vegetation down to the water's
edge the riparian buffer that's really
critical so when you start flipping into
that there's some areas you can deal
with projects so we did some big storm
water projects that both were effective
and they provided demonstrations but
you're getting into land use management
now you're flipping into a town zoning
and planning and enforcement issues
around use of private property and the
fella talking about
Winnipesaukee
winnipocket I I can relate to them it's
a tough conversation to have
um so you know we we did a number of
projects I think uh they're continuing
to do them up there it's been three
years since I've been there it's an
ongoing thing and I guess I would say I
think representative wrong mentioned you
know we can't control the temperature
and I think that's what we were seeing
in Newfound the phosphorus loading the
phosphorus is the primary nutrient in
fresh water
who was not changing a lot even with
land use changes in development maybe a
little bit but not a lot but the
temperature was going up I mean we saw
oh it used to be you'd never see
temperature a water temperature of 80
degrees and by the time I'd left three
years ago we were seeing it we'd seen it
for three or four years in a row or
three years out of five and that's
that's the trigger so a program like
this really has to build in resilience
I'm sorry if I'm too close it really has
to build in ecological resilience at the
Watershed scale to provide protection
against you know climate change
development growth
basically land use that is pretty much
the status quo for us so it's a it's a
bit of a push it's a it's a big
Communications push there's science
behind it there's there's politics
behind it this Communications behind it
and I think this I think these funds and
I agree most Lake Associations can't
afford them from a water drinking water
source you can always talk to your town
and you know deal with rates or a
capital bond issue or something like
that but we were a non-profit and bigger
than the guys you've heard before me but
uh we got almost a half a million
dollars in federal funding over a
10-year period that then we met
essentially matched with our labor and
our time so it was a million dollar
project over about a part of 10 years
thank you very much
any other questions for Mr Smith
Harvey bowley a representative Harvey
Bowie
thank you representative
um
uh Mr deers is talking about the large
amounts of federal funding for drinking
water grants and you had mentioned about
the source protection Source Waters to
the grants do you know
um can they be applied to the source
Waters or that's a great question I
don't have the answer to that I'd be
happy to dig into it and try and find
that out and get back to you it might
take me a couple three days if that's
okay
any other questions Mr wool
and thank you for taking my question one
of my concerns is I am up in the town of
Newbury representing Newbury and New
London and we've been trying to get our
three towns although they work well
together on a tax assessor they have a
joint tax assessor for three towns but
do uh can't seem to get three towns to
work together to come up with a
Environmental Management plan that
affects the lake
and the other lakes in there and my
concern on this is how do you get
two reading which I was surprised it's
only 20 percent but the 20 of the
problem that comes from septic systems
how do you somehow get those people who
are there just to inspect their system
Etc
yeah I you know I I came to the
conclusion that the um the critical
factor is political will
um the money helps I mean if you don't
have the money to do a study it's
probably not going to get done but once
you get the study done
um fact facts don't change people's
minds they've got to be feelings and
ultimately
you know there may be regulatory stuff
there I'm not that familiar I thought
you had to do some sort of an inspection
when your property changed hands but I
would certainly think at the local level
an ordinance could be put in place to to
inspect your septic system but that
really isn't my bailiwick I know the
state's got a you know got a department
that looks at septics and um but it's
getting the three towns to work together
you got to realize you know it and it's
an uphill push you know this is this is
our Golden Goose you know that's laying
the golden egg year after year and if we
don't take care of it what you know what
are we not doing it's and people haven't
had to take care of it stuff's
relatively new
thank you
any other questions for Mr Smith
seeing none thank you for your testimony
ship next I have uh Andrea lamaro New
good morning thank you uh chair and
committee for this opportunity to
comment uh I know that this is going
long and there's another hearing and
lots of people here in support so I'll
try to keep this brief so I'm Andrea
lamaro I'm the president of New
Hampshire Lakes New Hampshire Lakes is a
Statewide non-profit organization our
mission is to restore and preserve the
health of our lakes in New Hampshire
we represent about 2 000 individual
supporters and about a hundred local
Lake Associations and those local Lake
Associations each have some of them
hundreds of members I know you've heard
from many of our supporters and many of
our Lake Association Partners over their
email the past couple days and many are
sitting in this room today
um I'm also a lake resident and a lake
user my family has a home on like
Sunapee which has experience
cyanobacteria my husband's family has a
home on Seneca Lake in New York the
biggest finger Lake and it's been
experiencing horrendous cyanobacteria
blooms so I have personal experience I
know what a toxic cyanobacteria Bloom
can do to a lake to a family and a
community I have had to keep my kid out
of the water my niece and nieces and
nephews out of the water my dog
um my mother-in-law got sick from a
cyanobacteria bloom so first-hand
experience
but this morning I just really briefly
wanted to share with you two very quick
thing two things that I think this Loan
Fund could do um you've already heard
um this so I'll just sort of add on to
it but first our local communities Our
Lake Associations and their
municipalities generally they have a
pretty good idea of what's contributing
pollution to their lakes that is causing
these blooms there are there is some
financial assistance there are grants
we've talked about this there's Federal
funding available to Lake Associations
and municipalities with an approved
management plan to start pecking away at
these sources of pollution but the
funding is limited and it's given out
you know small chunks over a long period
of time it could take a look like
Association Newfound I'm on the board of
Newfound Region Lake Association and we
have a very long plan you know a 10 your
plan of implementing these projects that
are going to stop the pollution so we
know today what the problems are but
we're not going to be able to address it
all for 10 years and I'd like to suggest
that we don't have that time here to
wait this is happening now this Loan
Fund could help provide substantial
resources to get these sources of
pollution addressed in a relatively you
know quick or quicker time frame
the second point I wanted to make and
it's been brought up is with some
creative thinking I believe that this
Loan Fund could provide incentives and
Empower residents to upgrade repair
replace failing septic systems of Ted
and Norm mentioned that New Hampshire
Lakes runs the lake smart Lake friendly
Living Program through this free
voluntary program my team in the past
just two years we've met with 700
different Property Owners at their
properties in at 130 different Lake
communities
and basically come up with a customized
plan which each of these homeowners
Property Owners things that they could
do to reduce the amount of pollution
that their property and their activities
contributes to the lake and potentially
to toxic cyanobacterial blooms many
property owners have implemented
um improvements like friendly living
improvements a landscaping projects
roadway projects stuff like that on
their own on their own dime
we have through this program uh you know
had the displeasure unfortunate pleasure
of letting some Property Owners know
that their septic system is is not doing
well is not up to Snuff we don't have in
New Hampshire for various reasons uh
reliable numbers of troublesome systems
throughout the state Troublesome septic
systems nor do we really provide
incentives on the Statewide level to
help people find that out and then do
something about it so through this Lake
smart Lake friendly Living Program we
have asked Property Owners you know yes
replacing a septic system can be a
financial burden you know I think
there's a misconception sometimes that a
lakefront property owner you know has
the money and the resources to repair a
septic system that is not always the
case
um and so I've asked these folks if
there was some sort of program in your
community implemented by the Lake
Association or the municipality and
there are examples of this
um that you were provided some financial
assistance to repair the system you know
would this help and the answer is yes
again we have no idea the number of
troublesome systems around our Lakes but
local Lake Associations some in this
room have done really good surveys of
their Watershed and have found
several systems you know within 250 feet
of the lake that are older than um you
know 1967 when the permitting process
went in to a fact in New Hampshire so I
really do think this is an opportunity
if we think creatively to provide some
incentives and in New Hampshire finally
to help folks upgrade these systems
so with that I just want to urge you to
vote like your Lakes depend on it with
this because they do you know Lakes
clean and healthy Lakes are an urgent
threat under urgent
threats here and and it's time we do
something so happy to answer any
questions
representative Harvey polio
thank you uh representative Harbin thank
you for your testimony
um I was just wondering if you knew how
this the funds from this bill might be
used to address one of the issues that
was brought up by another speaker which
was to a homeowner moves in and puts in
a lawn and which produces a lot of
phosphorus
how would you keep such a thing from
happening
possibly through this uh the use of this
bill yeah that's a good question and I
think um this bill again if we think
creatively could present opportunities
for local communities associations
municipalities to provide cost share
grants or cost share opportunities for
folks to upgrade their properties to
make them more like friendly so that
property owner
um you know maybe needs to
maybe if they had an opportunity to make
their property more like friendly by
establishing you know vegetative buffer
on the other side of their lawn you know
maybe they'd be more apt to do that I
don't know if I'm exactly answering your
question but I do think there's an
opportunity here to
um
incentivize and financially assist
Property Owners to live in a more
seeing none thank you for your testimony
our next speaker is uh Mr Brian
Brian just a question is Abigail Adams
with you because you happen to be on the
same street in the same town she is who
would she like to come up with you we
can do both of you at one time
in fact uh thank you for the opportunity
to speak I will be very brief uh I'm
from Wolf bro I've been there since the
late 50s and uh I just wanted to present
one fairly concerning economic fact
let's take a lesson from Vermont a
Dartmouth study showed that property
values along Lake Champlain have fallen
30 percent because of cyanobacter
bacteria blooms and so this is a real
issue that we have to tackle and I'll
turn things over to my wife
I'm my name is Abby I always said the
last word
um
I couldn't resist my name is Abigail
Adams and I also live in Wolfeboro and
I'm a member of the Town committee
Wolfeboro Waters which is a committee of
volunteers appointed by the selectman to
advocate for water quality of our lakes
and ponds in Wolfeboro and I won't I'll
be very brief I think that two things
are true
nutrients such as phosphorus and
nitrogen are like candy to cyanobacteria
and that 80 percent of these nutrients
come from storm water runoff
usually from imperfectly developed land
that then allows water to run down
ashore into a water body or into a
culvert that reaches a water body
or roads and they don't have to be dirt
roads although they're particularly bad
um I think that
you know from personal reasons having
enjoyed being swimming in Lake
Winnipesaukee for the last 40 plus years
I hate to see this happening but also
just from an economic point of view
these are the jewels in our crown and in
the in the state of New Hampshire and
they are
essential to keeping our property values
and our tax base so I think I would
really urge you to think carefully about
funding anything you can do to decrease
the amount of
cyanobacteria outbreaks thank you for
letting me speak thank you any questions
thank you for the question just very
briefly can you maybe forward that study
reference sure thank you
any other questions
next speaker Brie Rossiter Lake
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is Bree
Rossiter I'm the conservation program
manager for the Lake Winnipesaukee
Association
we are the leading organization
dedicated to protecting the water
quality and natural resources of Lake
Winnipesaukee now and for future
Generations
Lake Winnipesaukee is a key economic and
recreational driver for the Lakes region
in 2021 the center of public policy at
Dartmouth College completed a policy
brief that estimated the economic value
of Lake Winnipesaukee at 17 billion
dollars
the largest contributor to this
valuation was property values which are
estimated at 16 billion dollars
and 445 million of that consist of
recreational opportunities which depend
on a clean and healthy Lake
over the last several years we have seen
an increase in cyanobacteria blooms on
Lake Winnipesaukee
in 2018 the first cyanobacteria advisory
was issued in Des on Winnie
and no advisories were issued from 2019
to 2021 but in 2022 there were four
advisories three alerts and 18 confirmed
observations
for the last 12 years we've been working
to address and reduce polluted
stormwater runoff through the
development of our watershed management
plans so as part of these plans we've
actually identified over 270 sites that
are in need of mitigation
to date we've been able to complete 50
projects at a cost of 1.2 million
dollars so these projects have resulted
in a reduction of approximately 85
pounds of
phosphorus entering the lake per year
157 pounds of nitrogen and 137
774 pounds of sediment
this is really significant because one
pound of phosphorus can support 500
pounds of algae growth therefore by
implementing these mitigation projects
the potential algal and cyanobacteria
growth has been reduced by 42 500 pounds
in Lake Winnipesaukee
overall I'd like to say that restoration
is expensive and as of you've heard from
everybody else funding is really
competitive so a loan program would
provide desperately needed funding to
increase the number and speed at which
these projects are accomplished
supporting House Bill 276 is very
important to ensure the continuation of
the economic Vitality in The Lakes
Region
thank you
thank you any questions from Mr Rossiter
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next speaker Mr Fred Quimby from New
Durham
foreign
thank you very much for having me here
today
uh I am Fred Quimby I'm a resident of
New Durham New Hampshire
and I am the chairman of the new Durham
water quality committee
and it's from that perspective that I'm
New Durham is a little town in New
Hampshire
it has about 2 000 residences
um
it has no centralized wastewater
treatment facility it has no centralized
what a distribution facility so
everybody in the town pretty much
depends on having their own well and
their own septic system
who Durham also has nine lakes and ponds
with sixteen hundred and forty Acres of
surface water as well as 84 miles of
now while locating a well
an aseptic system on a conforming lot
which a new Durham is 1.5 acres is not a
big deal
but unfortunately for the nearly one
half of all the residences that are
located within the shore land of those
water bodies
most of those properties are
non-conforming some as small as an
eighth of an acre
when you have an eighth of an acre of
land it doesn't allow you to even put in
a legal size leach field
and that's the problem I want to address
today
the largest lake we have in New Durham
is Mayor meeting like with the 1100
Acres
it's one of the cleanest water bodies in
the state of New Hampshire it has an
average phosphorus concentration of 4.5
pots per billion
that's really low
and despite the fact that our watershed
management planners had warned us
that Septic Systems Failing would be a
tremendous
make a tremendous impact on our Lake
we had not seen any cyanobacteria blooms
until two years ago
in 2021 we had two transient
cyanobacterial blooms again in 2022 we
had two cyanobacterial blooms
in the oldest part of the lake many of
the homes were built in the 1920s
that also happens to be with the lots
are the smallest
it also happens to be a place where some
people just have holding tanks they
can't locate a septic system
so our community has begun to look into
purchasing a common piece of land away
from the Waterfront and putting in a
community leach field system to take
care of those people with the old
the bill that has been proposed here
would really help our municipality with
a long-term loan
and allow us to be able to fund such a
thank you for your testimony any
seeing none again thank you for your
time
our next speaker
Julie Brown Wentworth Watershed
different
good morning and thank you for hearing
my testimony my name is Julie Brown I'm
the director for the Wentworth Watershed
Association and also sit on wolfborough
Waters committee I'm an advisory panel
for the town
the Wentworth Watershed Association has
been in existence in some portion for
almost over a hundred years we've been
monitoring the Waters of the seventh
largest water body in the state Lake
Wentworth Crescent Lake and Sergeant's
pond
we work collaboratively with a town
to address Watershed issues do education
and Outreach and are a strong voice in
the community to lead people in the
right direction including our membership
which is over 800 residents many of
which are shorefront Property Owners but
also residents who are in the actual
Watershed week by land we can serve land
we install infiltration
Trend infiltration bmps through the
watershed management assistance grants
or the 319 grants we have a watershed
management plan that we put into effect
in 2012 and we are actually redoing our
watershed management plan at this point
because we have addressed the top 20
issues so we are tapping into all
available funds for cyanobacteria
monitoring for technology we're working
with our municipality we're working with
des and EPA to address these issues and
what is very clear is cyanobacteria is
becoming a prevalent issue in the state
for all water bodies big and small
shallow and deep and the funding that's
available to protect the state waters is
very limited and now that cyanobacteria
has become this um
the canary and the coal mine a lot of
other organizations are tapping into the
funds which is amazing so the Watershed
assistant Grant funds through the EPA is
very limited annually and this year for
the first year ever we did not receive
our 319 Grant because they allocated the
funds to more to other organizations
which is amazing for them but what it's
doing is slowing down our hard work so
the state needs to really look at how
can we use taxpayer dollars to further
support the work of these organizations
Beyond what's already there and this
revolving fund with 10 forgiveness is a
good start we need funding and we need
to do things now not wait and so even
having a setback by one year could
really affect the work that we're doing
in the effectiveness of it and in all
honesty the state owns the water and all
of these new municipalities and all of
us organizations with non-profit dollars
and that members are paying above and
beyond to be members to do the work
needs to be met by the state saying we
care about your Waters we care about the
economy and this is a good step in the
right direction Recreation I know you're
the recreation committee
that's what brings all of the funding to
our town all the jobs if we don't have
our Lakes
we don't have a healthy economy and we
don't have a healthy community and we
don't have healthy residents and we
don't have younger residents walking to
the state which our state so desperately
needs so I urge you to step in the right
direction and further support
cyanobacteria mitigation by providing
loans to municipalities to organizations
like my own and really look to the
future of how we can
um care and show the state taxpayers
that we care about our Fresh Water
Resources so I thank you for supporting
this bill
seeing none thank you for your testimony
our next speaker David rochefort
Mr Roche
thank you good morning
Mr Vice chair and members of the
committee um
I'm from the so I'm a representative in
Littleton but I'm not here as a
representative I'm here as a property
owner and a member of The Partridge Lake
Property Owners Association and uh so
Partridge lake is a is a small Lake
about a hundred acres in Littleton and
we have our own story about cyanoco
bacteria which I'm going to try to cut
short a little bit uh because we had a
long morning already but when I was
driving down here this morning I was
driving through the Notch and and going
through the hills and and looking up I
realized that this issue that we're
talking about here today and it was
brought up the Des mentioned it too this
started 120 years ago this isn't
something new that just popped up out of
out of out of nowhere and it was in my
opinion my it was first recognized by
John Wingate weeks John Wingate weeks
like myself as a native of Lancaster he
went on to be a rep representative in
Massachusetts and went to Congress or
Massachusetts and what he noticed in
Massachusetts and in Southern New
Hampshire in the round of the turn of
the century is that the Mills and the
rivers were getting loaded with silt in
addition to being loaded with silt there
were uncontrolled wildfires up in the
northern part of the state and this was
a result of the widespread unmitigated
deforestation my opinion what we're
seeing today was cyanobacteria started
with that deforestation 120 years ago
we've talked about a lot about today
about phosphorus so those of us who
remember our chemistry courses
phosphorus is a element it's a basic
element and it's probably the original
forever chemical right I mean it doesn't
it doesn't go away so when all of our
trees were cut down and all of our our
Hills were turned into to grazing land
all of that phosphorus from manure and
natural deposits and and fertilizer all
flowed downhill and in our case in
Littleton it flowed right into Partridge
Lake we're right at the bottom of a bowl
we have a sheep farm or a former sheep
farm on one end a former cattle farm on
the other and again unlike some of the
stories we've heard we have a I'm fairly
new to the lake but fortunately for us
we have some real real sharp people who
have a lot of foresight about 30 years
ago they realized that we've got to do
something to make sure that our water is
protected so in addition to invasive
species they started looking at septic
systems and they put together the
Partridge Lake Property Owners
Association and they raised money you
know private money they went for Grants
and they started 30 years ago replacing
septic systems educating the property
owners about phosphorus and its effects
they we have a you know to speak to one
of the questions by representative Darby
every Every Spring we get out and we
clean the sides of the roads and we
clean the the
volunteers clean out the the culverts to
really look at that anything that we can
do to mitigate this egg that exogenous
sources of phosphorus that's still
coming you can't get rid of it so our
association started taking steps 30
years ago to hopefully avoid you know
cyanobacteria and other things we've we
have commissioned a number of studies
that I know the Des has has mentioned uh
we identified where our phosphorus is
coming from yes we do have external
phosphorus that continues to come in but
based on the stuff we've done locally
we've largely we've addressed a lot of
that but we have a natural phosphorus
slug in the bottom of our Lake as a
result of 120 years of rain going into
to the bottom of the lake
so we support this bill because this is
exactly where our Lake Association we're
ready for the next step
um our like I said we've invested a lot
of money and time into studies and we've
understood that there is some mitigation
that could be done but as much as we've
invested this would be a good uh
opportunity for us to to borrow the
money to take those next next level
mitigation steps which would be some
continuing excavation and some Alum
treatments that would uh that would go a
long way so again thinking about
representative weeks and by the way
representative weeks did that and he
took action I got a man in his his work
ended up in the weeks act as you
probably know which started the national
forest so the White Mountain National
Forest was started in all the national
forests was the work from a New
Hampshire native so we here in New
Hampshire have an opportunity through
276 to continue that work let's finish
this and let's get 276 available to us
let's get those loan funds so we've got
a bunch of people who are really willing
to work really willing to to do the work
and this is that that 276 will be the
tool that does that so
I'm on Ways and Means and we talk about
taxes a lot and where we get our money
from and uh New Hampshire does not have
a sales tax we do not have an income tax
but we do have 800 plus bodies of water
and those people that are coming to
visit those 800 plus bodies water they
they pay our meals and rooms taxes they
buy property they buy fishing licenses
they buy gas they buy homes they shop at
our businesses so this is more than just
a bunch of property owners trying to
protect their backyards this is a real
resource that the state has an economic
resource that we can protect here so on
behalf of the Partridge Lake Properties
Owners Association we urge you to
support 276.
thank you representative any questions
for representative rochefort
representative wolf
just a quick one
um that I probably should have asked the
gentleman from Des before but in a
situation that you have that's 120 plus
years old that's the primary cause of
your phosphorus loading can you do a
mitigation that is
cost effective successful
we're convinced who you can yes
um you know we had a the Des came up
last summer to do a presentation to our
properties Association uh Property
association we've applied for the EPA
planning Grant
um we've gone through and worked with
our town uh through warrant articles to
guarantee some of these things
um you know we've been very active for
the last 30 years and we're convinced
that with the external workings of
drainage and and and working with the
culverts and how the water gets into our
Our Lake and also treating the lake
we're convinced that uh that that this
is a viable option we wouldn't be here
supporting this if if we didn't
follow-up
thank you
um
that I understand and I'm well behind
the septic thing
septic research and replacement the
drainage and all but it seems to me that
your problem is 50
120 years ago yeah so I mean it's it's
the the problem started a hundred let me
go back because we had no trees back
then so you know the drainage just
flowed in and now we do have trees
the Farms that were surrounding the lake
are no longer there in fact remember
they're people around the lake that
bought some of that property to ensure
that it would never become
you know developed again to add into our
lake so we have and actually we have
been complimented by the Des on the
actions that we've taken thus far to to
to limit that external sources of
phosphorus and in fact if you look at
that we we have done like I said we have
done a number of studies on our own and
if you look at some of that data we have
taken a a a huge chunk out of the
external loading of our lake so we have
already even up to this point largely
eliminated that largely eliminated that
it's negligible at this point now the
part that we would use this fund is to
treat the phosphorus that's in there and
we're essentially going to bind it so it
so it can't act as food for the
cyanobacteria
any other questions for the
representative representative Harvey
bowley
thank you just a quick question uh thank
you for your testimony and can you
describe elaborate a little bit more how
you would do this binding uh and and
treating of the water thank you yeah so
uh fortunately Des I believe is still
here so if we get into some more
chemical uh stuff that then that they
can they can come save me but
um the the process is actually we don't
do it a lot in New Hampshire and I think
he alluded to the fact that we're just
not set up regulatory wise to do it and
it hasn't been a a widespread issue
until probably 10 years ago but there is
a treatment of Alum a-l-u-m that's used
um in Lakes it's been widely used
throughout other parts of the country I
know when they came to to do the
presentation this summer I I said I've
never heard of this so you know I did my
own research and
um it's been widely used in the midwest
Illinois Iowa those are the states that
I came across
okay studies where it's been done and
you know they you know
at a high level they they determine how
much they their Studies have to go into
to the lake then they determine how much
of this stuff has to be applied to the
lake uh they apply it to the certain
areas of the lake where the phosphorus
is settled on the bottom in higher
concentrations and uh and it you know
there's a binding effect to it and it
deactivates the phosphorus so it can't
act as a as a nutrient because now
you've got a chemical reaction that that
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you representative
thank you for your testimony
I have no more pink cards is there
anyone that didn't fill out a pink card
that wants to speak on HB 276.
seeing no one approaching the mic I'm
going to declare the hearing on HB 276
closed
so
foreign
I always thought you were a kind and
all right let me just got the bill let's
get this on the road
I'd like to call to order a house bill
534 relative to water assistance for
natural disasters I represent our res I
I recognize representative Boyd Mr
chairman thank you very much I
appreciate it and through you to my
esteemed colleagues of the resources
Recreation and development committee my
name is Bill Boyd I represent Hillsboro
District 12 in the town of Merrimack
I also serve as chairman of the New
Hampshire drinking water and groundwater
advisory commission
um worthy of note your colleague
representative Gould is also a
distinguished member of the commission
as well where she has served with with
the plum and integrity during her time
on the tenure so I'm very grateful for
her service to the commission this bill
specifically creates a water assistance
fund to deal with replacing drinking
water sources that have been damaged by
by natural disasters and natural
disasters obviously over the last uh
three to four years New Hampshire has
been in what I would call a significant
drought now lately we're no longer in
that drought and I'll get to that point
um a little further along but the
Genesis behind this bill emanated from
my commission uh back in 2020 where we
were approached by the chairman of the
commission at that time Senate President
Chuck Morse worked with
um staff from Des to come up with an
emergency funding program
uh where we allocated 1.5 million
dollars to Target at need homeowners
that needed recovery in order to have
access to clean potable water we created
a two-tiered system one tier which
allowed a homeowner to pay a deductible
into the program in a tier two a tier 2
component which was based strictly on
need based on the mhi qualifications
that have that the federal government
has has promulgated
um
behind me and I forgot to make my
introductions to commissioner Scott and
the administrator of the trust fund Dr
Cheryl Bondi she can obviously get
granular more onto the details of the of
the fund but the focus is to build upon
what the commission had done has done
over the last
three years as it relates to improving
the quality of of home of homeowners
needing access access to water right now
with
the uh the commission we've already
allocated 3.2 million dollars we've
spent
2.75 so right now roughly about 400 400
000 is a 400 400 000 is is unobligated
we're looking to create this program to
be managed directly through the
Department of Environmental Services so
that the the commission can pivot
into what it was originally designed
under under 485 which is to provide
cost-sharing grants and cost sharing
loan money is targeting on uh pollution
and contamination issues Source water
development
um infrastructure getting municipalities
over the hump with some with some of
their water water projects so that
from from that standpoint Des can create
the specific rules so that they can
independently uh administer the program
to again work with homeowners that may
have experienced an a natural disaster
um
these last couple of years not
necessarily I mean the Southern Tier of
New Hampshire I would say has been
impacted but I would also argue that
it's been the the North Country uh
people in in the central part of New
Hampshire
um that have been impacted by the
drought where Wells have dried up and
they've applied to the commission for
for assistance in having a driller
coming out to either do some fracking
work or to try and reperk the old well
or find a new location for a well to be
able to provide potable water in getting
a driller out to these locations has
been especially challenging the the
Drillers that we have in state are
pretty much working 24 7 365
with very little with very little
bandwidth they're constantly uh going
out not just with the Hallmarks that
come through our program but through
other other developments that may be
going on in the state where they're
actually doing the work trying to to
create create and Bill Wells for for
either homeowners or developers so in
coming full circle because I certainly
want to answer answer your questions
um
the last last three years at the
commission
um
what originally started out as as an
emergency program
emerged into something where we're
having a positive value on
on homeowners that that are for the lack
of a better term and I apologize for
them that are Income challenge that may
not be able to that don't have the
wherewithal to be able to
um fund the development or Redevelopment
of the of their own Wells so
um I'm very proud of one of the things I
do want to amplify is I'm very proud of
the the level of technical expertise
that we have on the commission we've had
a representative from uh Concord Water
Works in pennichuck
um his name is Jason Gagnon I forget who
Jason works for but he does a lot of
work up in the North Country Andrea
Cantor again we've had significant
professional technical expertise that
has worked on on a myriad of projects
like this that have come through the
commission that has allowed us to be
able to make sure that these that these
projects as it relates to the lawn
program that that
that they're cost efficient they're
effective in in this solving a problem
and obviously we can't do any of that
good work without the good Folks at DES
commissioner Scott Dr Bondi and the rest
of the team at DES for the Yeomans work
that they do uh day in and day out not
just for this program but for the
success of my commission so
um again you have my letter I would
encourage you to please read my letter
which kind of puts uh some more more
flesh on the skeleton that explains the
goals and I certainly would be more than
happy to entertain any questions and I
thank the chairman and the committee for
any questions by members of the board of
remember representative McHugh thank you
Mr chairman thank you representative
Boyd for bringing this bill for uh for
the whole state and and of course for
our district since half the
delegation is in the room
um
can you tell us a little bit about how
this bill affects not just the town of
Merrimack our district but the whole
state I I think it may have come as a
surprise it did a little bit to me uh
that the state's been in drought
conditions uh for a while and so I don't
want people to think it's just a
Merrimack bill that it really is a whole
State issue
but can you elaborate a little bit on
that absolutely and I appreciate the
question thank you very much
representative
um
the state of New Hampshire
relies on two things we rely on snow and
those materials to make its way from the
north down south into our groundwater to
be able to fill our Lakes feel rivers
and streams and be able to percolate the
the aquifers that exist throughout our
state in the last four years you know
those particular levels have been have
been extremely small for the for the
lack of a better term and
since my time on the commission and and
then since joining the legislature
um and being a part of this commission
we've always been given updates in in
if it's if it's not red it's orange if
it's not Orange it's yellow there's
never anything opaque that's on the map
that that suggests that we're out of a
drought now
not not the name drop but um Mur
meteorologist Haley Lapointe just
indicated to us that we're really no
longer in a in a drought situation Dr
Bondi also confirmed that for me but
well that's well that's good news for
the interim that we're out of a drought
situation
all it takes is to go several leaks
without any rain that's going to to
siphon that snowpack is going to snipe
and the siphon that that rain water away
from from doing what it needs to do and
subsequently those levels of groundwater
that are necessary to to fill our wells
and to fill our reservoirs and and to be
able
um to fill our ribs to let the the
Public Water Systems be able to do its
job it's going to have is having a
significant impact at that particular
level so circling back to your original
question you know we we rely on Mother
Nature
to be able to provide clean potable
water to every single Granite stator
that lives here in New Hampshire and if
Mother Nature regretfully is not not
doing the job that we've asked her to do
then you know certain situations are
occur I.E private homeowner Wells are
drying up and they are left without a
resource to be able to get into to
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question and that that's really
helpful when I read your test
testimonial coffee this morning I
thought water natural disasters floods
so in our district the flood that I
think of is the like Wildcat Falls
Beacon Drive that's where we have floods
every year so for the the Merrimack
constituents is this money accessible
for that type of situation that flood
zone that I think of in for those
Merrimack residents maybe listening to
this so if a flood contaminates a
private well and that homeowner meets
the income qualifications that would
allow income qualifications in the
criteria to have the application be
reviewed for consideration the answer is
yes this helps them great so it helps
them so this criteria that's involved
that that need to be met in order for a
homeowner to be able to receive uh
funding from the program and and in in
in Fierce Dr Dr Bondi put this together
I mean looking at some of the
applications I mean it's
I mean in the southern part of the state
I mean Dairy had applications Kingston
had applications Hampstead had
applications Hudson had applications and
then you go to places like Tamworth and
Jaffrey and Jefferson
um you know so it's it's not limited to
you know the obviously we think of the
Southern Tier being more
having more readily accessible access to
resources such as infrastructure to be
able to to tap into a public water
source like Hawk like pentachuck like
for represented by Merrimack Village
Water District for the North Country
those those resources are very limited
private Wells are necessary to provide
potable water to the to the house so
it's a process correct is this a is this
a drop in the bucket sorry no further
questions yeah okay
is this a drop in the bucket so this
what is what I would say a necessary
first step to continuing the mission
that the commission has set out
regarding being able to provide a
funding program to
uh income challenge homeowners so the
impetus being by putting it in you know
by having it being a part of a line item
and Des allows them you know greater
autonomy they're allowed a rule set
they're allowed to be creative in
working with homeowners to to get in
there to help them to meet the criteria
so that's the way that I would look at
it thank you yep you're welcome
anyone else representative
Erin and thank you representative Boyd
for taking my question and thank you
very much for bringing this bill forward
and recognizing the need to help people
out with ensuring they have safe
drinking water my question is is the
intent of the bill particularly on
looking at line 13
uh it's to provide for the replacement
repair and treatment of private Drinking
Water Resources but when I look at the
fiscal note from Des it says it's for
repair and replacement of drinking water
treatment sources and I was just
wondering if
um
is there do you see a difference between
sources of drinking water and drinking
water treatment sources so it's what do
you say that I picked up on that as well
oh okay and I and I I actually
um I would need to talk offline with
commissioner Scott and Dr Bondi about
that so that
one has to be compatible with the other
uh from from a language standpoint but I
I appreciate the nuance
any other questions
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um very naive question but are there
um options available for private
insurance for Wells to to you know to
account for natural disasters like the
are for fun floods representative Darby
thank you for the question and it's it's
not naive it's a it's a good question
because when you have a homeowner's
insurance depending on where you live if
you live in a flood plain flood
insurance is generally a requirement of
of home of home ownership as it relates
and relates to national disasters
natural disasters excuse me I
I would be speaking off the top of my
head and my initial inclination would be
that if there was a proclivity like
let's say living not not to bring up
another state but if we were living in
California on the San Andreas fault I
would think that you know earthquake
earthquake insurance would not be a
supplemental Rider I would think that
would be a component but earthquakes in
New Hampshire are a rarity but I would
contend to you since there has been an
uptick in in geospatial shifts here in
New Hampshire that the possibility of an
earthquake impacting an aquifer which
impacts a neighborhood of private Wells
that suddenly a well that was flushed
with water automatically goes dry yeah
that's that's a concern whether or not
that's something that a homeowner would
need to buy to ensure
um I I honestly wouldn't know the
question but I would think that it's
possible that it could be an insurable
event
would you consider the need to have a
to include not just natural disasters
but if someone has a contamination of
their water source
from a organic chemical or non-agamic so
the the the target
for this bill is
is natural disasters there's other
legislation your colleague has a has a
bill going through right now that
specifically targets uh pfos I've signed
on to a Senate bill that targets pfos my
commission um as it relates to
contamination issues we're dealing uh
we're dealing with the gamut not just
pfas but
um Iron manganese arsenic there are
there's at least one or two communities
that has naturally organic uranium that
is occurring that is polluting drinking
well sources so
um
the intent is to and I don't mean to be
uh have the bill be myopic but is it is
focused targeting need towards
homeowners that have seen their Wells
gone dry and uh need need assistance in
being able to be able to provide clean
potable water to not just themselves but
the but the family or the people that
live in their house but it's a fair
anyone else from the members of the
committee for a question
I guess Scrooge has the his chance to so
I will have a question I was hoping you
would Mr chair yes
um
our
what what is the well first of all
why can this not be available to all
people
well it is it's going to be no no it's
only available to people at a certain
income level
okay I apologize I apologize and I
apologize too I shouldn't have gone back
and forth but I should have asked myself
for if I could do another question and
then we noticed and and I and I will ask
the uh
at
you know the originally you're
your organization was based around
basically pollution correct which is
base which was something unforeseen
yeah uh not unexpected
correct correct another question
and uh
this
natural disaster
is
we have all we have now we have many
natural disasters and we take care of
them now
uh what makes what makes this different
well let me just leave it at that
what I'm I don't mean to be deaf I don't
understand what you're what you mean by
using the word different I apologize
well we have we have other net we have
natural disasters we've had them since
you know time immemorial and the state
has been able to react to them in in as
in a normal way and we we have we do
react to natural disasters
uh
why is all of a sudden
this taken is a different what what is
what it why is this uh of such
importance that it can't be handled in
the in the in the normal way we handle
natural disasters in this state so the
natural disasters and this is this is me
my knowledge and if I'm wrong hold me in
contempt
um
usually there is a federal disaster
declaration that's made as it relates to
the state so if if we were to take
Hampton Beach in
title surge in the title search totally
you know flooding Hampton Beach and you
you know for the most part Hampton beach
is on a public water system there are in
some select houses on along the beach
that have a private well so let's let's
assume those those Wells get tainted by
the salt water that came over came over
the wall and permeated those Wells
I would presume not assume I would
presume that the federal disaster
declaration and that FEMA funds would be
made available for that homeowner to be
able to apply to be able to remediate
that particular well because the well is
now tainted with with salt water
droughts
as of today and I I I'm trying to go
back and look at new sources as it
relates to the droughts that are
occurring are occurring out in the west
like Arizona Wyoming Colorado California
Nevada I am trying to remember if
there's ever been a federal disaster
declaration that that has been made as
it relates to that kind of an event now
I could be wrong but I don't I don't
remember any so in looking at the
drought situation here in New Hampshire
which is classified as as a natural
disaster without having that formal
declaration we're leaving a segment of
we're leaving a six segment of granite
Staters that don't have that some may
have the wherewithal to fix it but those
that don't have their for the again for
the lack of a better word they're
probably left out on a Lurch without
having any particular direction by
having this specific program being
administered enrolled under the guise of
guys of Des and and I can say
having watched them at work over the
last three years and Minister the
programs for the commission
um the the the actual the the
application process the attention to
detail the use of the criteria the rule
making I'm confident that that those
specific processes would carry over
should should this program be enacted
and implemented into law I'm I'm fairly
comfortable that Des has the the
technical expertise in the
professionalism to to administer the
program so back to your original
question I think there's a difference
when when you don't have a federal
Declaration of a natural disaster you're
going to have a certain segment of
society that's that's flounder and being
able to provide them an Avenue of
approach to hopefully fix or remediate
that problem I think is is noteworthy
and it's something that I personally
feel
um we've had success with it and I
really want to continue the program I
think it's it's a good thing to have and
I in our community in our community in
our state
thank you is there anyone else wishes to
thank you representative
um thank you for your testimony
representative Boyd are you familiar
with uh the agent that that's the United
States Department of Agriculture Farm
Service Agency has a disaster assistance
program for Drought recovery and have
you how does is that uh so the the
DOA Department of agriculture's program
is actually part of our criteria when
we're looking at applications for some
of the programs you know not just not
the one program so this is done as an
aside
um to what the commission addresses in
looking at criteria for how we make our
grant Awards to municipalities that are
doing Source water protection
infrastructure you know Wellhead
protection um actually buying up land to
protect that so there are specific
criteria that the Department of
Agriculture has as it relates to that
program now I've actually looked at the
criteria to that particular program and
I kind of look at that criteria more as
a regional approach or a municipal
approach to a problem as opposed to an
individual homeowner approach now I
could be wrong because I candidly I
didn't get into the weeds in in looking
at it fully but that was one of the
things I did look at in preparation and
prior to sponsoring this bill to see if
there was
um anything else available to homeowners
or property owners that they can make
seeing none thank you very much Mr
chairman three of my colleagues thank
perfect
uh
representative Mary Hawkins Phillips
they pronounce did I pronounced
I mean the Phillips yeah I'll be honest
representative I couldn't hear from back
here but um for the record my name is
Mary hacken Phillips I represent Grafton
County District 12. the towns of Hanover
and lime thank you for the the time to
address you today
so I'm here today speaking on as a
co-sponsor on behalf of HB 534 for four
main reasons I support this bill
first this past summer representative
Boyd and I made a commitment to each
other to find ways to work together
across the aisle and we've made a point
to find and support good legislation
regardless of the party that introduces
it
today HB 534 represents good legislation
um and as it's been introduced by my
honorable colleague
um representative Boyd I just
hope and invite you all to consider you
know the option to join in bipartisan
ship today
second it's my sincere hope that all
legislators can agree that access to
clean water is a necessity to a healthy
and prosperous Granite State regardless
of where you live
an example of why I think this bill is
so critical is that I have a constituent
in the Aetna area who recently noticed
their well was running dry and if you're
not familiar with where Aetna is it's a
small village just to the east of
um one December afternoon this
constituent had run a couple of loads of
laundry and ran their dishwasher and
noticed at dinner time that their Taps
started to run dry
after Consulting with professionals they
learned that their well was indeed
running dry it's not refilling at a you
know proper rate fast enough to keep
Pace with their regular household needs
so the reason they found out was a
variety of some factors but it was
exacerbated by the ongoing drought that
the state is experiencing
when they inquired as to how long it
would take and how much money it would
take to remedy the situation they
learned it's going to take thousands of
dollars to find a new well
and it would take several weeks before a
driller could come and process the
location so you know thankfully this
family has the resources to pay the
premium price of Expediting that new L
to be drilled in an emergency situation
but we all know that not every family in
the granite state has resources to pay
for emergency Wells to be drilled on
their property when they need it
there's many families who are struggling
to meet their day-to-day costs and their
living paycheck to paycheck they don't
have several thousand dollars to ensure
that they have safe clean water at home
these folks also deserve access to clean
water just the same I think you'll agree
many believe that clean water is an
access uh clean water access is an
equality issue and providing access to
those who can't afford it is the right
thing to do especially when you're faced
with natural natural disasters
you know my example is not the kind of
natural disaster one might think of
um you know more immediately like a
tornado or an earthquake or a huge you
know hundred year flood
but the long-term drought conditions are
making natural disaster scenarios very
real for our state and what better cause
than to support our most vulnerable
citizens in securing clean water after a
natural disaster
the third reason I think about is that
we all know our state is obviously
experiencing this drought condition and
we need to think about the true costs of
the slow-moving phenomenon
although in recent months our state has
drought conditions have lessened the
real dangers of long-term effects of
this drought and future possible
droughts is very real
the cost of drought are not only related
to the environment and natural resources
there's a very real financial and
economic concern that the state will
face the short-term allocation included
in this bill proposes a great start
it's going to be preventing long-term
more painful and higher material costs
by the state when economically depressed
rural areas lose access to clean water
and are forced to migrate to areas with
more access
in other words it's going to cost more
to move from you know out in the
countryside with a private well into you
know more infrastructure supported Urban
centers
I'd like to just break down this
argument it's far Cheaper to Keep people
where they are longer than to support
them in finding a new location as a
state we should be prepared to deal with
that
and these drought like conditions and
the long term and this is a great way to
to begin that process
my fourth point is that this bill is one
more piece of legislation to help solve
our housing crisis which is plaguing our
state
solving the housing crisis is a
multi-layered
you know multi-level effort and it's you
know any small piece that you can add to
the puzzle to keep vulnerable people in
their homes should be undertaken giving
our housing stock shortages
imagine losing your well after a natural
disaster and being forced to move with
no place to go
let's do our part Let's help increase
well access so that our poorest
community members only have to deal with
one crisis at a time
and some I'd like to urge you to join
this bipartisan effort in support of
this bill and give the legislation the
Bridge Building ought to pass that it
deserves trust me it feels good to reach
across the aisle and support good
legislation if it means Granite Staters
will be their lives will be improved I'd
like to thank you for your time and I'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have
any questions by members of the
committee
yeah turn it on thank you good afternoon
Mr chair and members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Bob Scott I'm
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services and
I'm also a I serve on the drinking water
groundwater trust fund and also
um
I do have some of my team are still here
we've been in the audience all morning
uh I have uh Dr Bondi as as
uh representative Boyd mentioned she's
the administrator of the the trust fund
the drinking water groundwater trust
fund uh and and uh we have director
Pelletier is behind me also uh director
of The Water Division which includes our
drinking water program so our hope is if
there's any questions we could certainly
try to answer those for you so briefly
uh as I pass out my the testimony
letters going around uh as mentioned
already this program it
effectively exists already through the
auspicious of the drinking water ground
lawyer trust fund uh since 2021 we've
we've this need for this needs-based
program we've been able to provide
assistance to about 147 private well
owners uh since then uh the intent uh in
my view for the trust fund it was not to
be a permanent forever thing for the
things that are funded out of the trust
fund uh but meant to be you know we've
as you're well aware probably we've done
injections of money for infrastructure
and other things this program we feel
has been very successful but the intent
was uh at this point since it seems to
be something that's needed moving
forward uh to codify it and also get
obviously legislative support
um so I briefly I can also answer some
questions uh as mentioned I think we had
a question about the current drought
today we are not in a status state of
drought for most of the state 8 whether
we would be in the spring and again so
far we've had three years of drought uh
if the question is are we going into
year four it really depends on the
recharge the aquifers and the amount of
snowpack now snowpack looks like it's
getting better right now uh but we're
not done with the winter yet so it's an
open question whether we'll go into year
four I will tell you that in the past
three years we've been in severe drought
in different parts of the State uh and
then answer the question is this just a
Merrimack thing actually it's not been
much of a Merrimack thing it's it's been
wherever the most severe drought is uh
in the past three years so it's been
more the North country in the past years
this last year in 2022 it was mostly in
the Southern Tier where most of the
population is also
I had some other thoughts but I can't
remember what they were
um so the other thing I will mention uh
certainly we support the program we
think is very needed the other question
I think was uh some questions on what
other things other than drought is it
used for I'll give you a great example
which will answer two things as far as
need and and I think the chair had asked
is there you know can't I think
effectively doesn't FEMA take care of
this type of thing and you know are
there other resources so if you go back
uh prior to covid we had a flooding
event on the baker River I don't know if
some of you remember that where we had a
house going down channel nine on on
Channel Nine a house going down the
river in Warner Warren rather
um that that scouring of that River
caused by that event actually lowered
the water table for some wells in that
local community uh that wasn't really
funds available for those private Wells
if some of you may remember at the time
Senator gaida he did a GoFundMe page so
help people the director of sem at the
time was able to they had small amounts
of money but not nearly enough to cover
people for the wells being drilled that
were needed that's it the type of thing
where it's not necessarily covered by
FEMA and it's not necessarily drought
related but those are that's an example
real world example in New Hampshire
where this this program could have
provided that kind of assistance because
those were low-income residents as I
remember so so with that my last
statement would be we strongly support
the program it's a it's a viable program
uh this this legislation would give us
authority to do rule making so there'd
be a whole public process there on what
we should do we do intent to to should
this pass to uh have the the rule making
uh very closely mirror what we're
currently doing
uh and my last Point uh and as much as
we love the program uh you'll note in my
testimony letter we're not taking a
position on the source of funding uh
we're well aware there's multiple
competing interests for funding right
now uh I will assure you that with this
bill and other bills that are for the
funding
um that we we have and will if if we're
the agency does get the money uh spend
it very effectively and uh make it go as
far as possible so with that I'm happy
to answer any questions and again I have
people smarter than me behind me that
thank you very much uh as representative
uh wrong
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
commissioner for coming
um following up on a question I asked
representative Boyd regarding the um uh
fiscal note
is is that just a a typo error on the
behalf of Des it would be to replace
drinking water sources not drinking
water treatment sources
that's correct so the intent of the
program and the way we've administered
it so far through the trust fund is if
there's a permanent impact to make the
well either dry or just unpotable water
that and you have the the the income
qualifications that would be the
qualification so it doesn't need to be
just for treatment uh so so I agree
that's the drafting error for our fiscal
okay thank you
okay
any other questions members of the
committee
representing Darby
I think you missed the chair
um I'm trying to understand the numbers
here so you've spent it seems like this
is the ideas is the continuation of a
program that has spent 2.5 million since
2021 that's like 1.25 per year and this
is doubling it up as at least as far as
I see so
um can you explain the justification for
the doubling of fundsa
certainly there is obviously the
existing need moving forward which is
notional right so for instance we of of
late we've been spending the funds for
Drought impacts and as I mentioned we're
not sure what's going to happen in the
future the other part of this program
again is as mentioned it's not just for
droughts for you know natural disasters
and those are hard to predict uh so
Summits the other rationale I guess is
if we're on this if we worst case we're
on the same trajectory for for droughts
we we understand our spending trajectory
but also we want a reserve if you will
for those again uh there's an earthquake
as as uh representative Boyd mentioned
or a major hurricane uh puts you know
put salt in you know some of the
aquifers and the Seacoast I'm not hoping
for any of this obviously uh but so so
we we do want to be able to to have a a
a amount of money there to be able to
react quickly obviously if beyond that
hopefully FEMA and others will step in
and perhaps there'll be time for the
legislature to step in but we really
want this program to be the a place to
go so they and having it within the
department not requiring a vote of you
know the trust fund or that type of
thing where we can't act very agilely in
an agile way so
um it's not necessarily hopefully we'll
never use the money to be to be blunt
but the money we would like the money to
be there for those instances should that
happen
thank you
for your testimony and I was wondering
if there are other uh I know there are
other home assistance programs in New
Hampshire government home assistance
programs and and how those May overlap
with this one
can people apply for funds to other New
Hampshire home assistance programs for
the same thing thank you
I'm uh not as expert in this uh I I will
say like you know and again I'll try to
answer questions that were asked in the
past too so you know the insurance
question for instance I'd have two
comments many insurance policies do not
talk about Force Major and and sometimes
you know a natural disaster would be
that and second of all uh again we're
looking at uh income need here and and
uh
those people are least likely to be able
to pay for insurance or have insurance
uh so so I I didn't answer your question
representative but I'm not I guess I'm
not sure I don't know if any of my staff
have any other thoughts behind me if the
chair would indulge
so yes
everybody okay
yeah okay
you could have two friends in the booth
hi thank you I'm Cheryl Bondi from Des
and could you please repeat your
question
bye
that's it um I was just one I know there
are other New Hampshire Home assistants
programs grants uh for low-income
homeowners to receive uh to many to
mitigate
problems in their homes so I was
obviously the programs will overlap so
you could address that thanks as far as
I'm aware there are no other funding
programs available for private well
assistance so the drinking water
groundwater trust fund has other funding
programs for uh Community water systems
and Municipal systems so through through
that funding source there is no
overlapping
um
you had mentioned the USDA Rural
programs as far as I know folks that
apply to this program the water systems
for natural disasters they have already
exhausted outside
um options of funding and they have to
show that they've uh that their home
insurance doesn't cover it so they're
they're coming to us as a last resort
they've already exhausted outside
options if they exist are available to
them
thank you anyone else
seeing no one
thank you very much
finals
uh Mr graze
New Hampshire Municipal Association
thank you Mr chair I'm well aware that
I'm probably the person keeping all of
you from lunch so I will be very brief
um I've been very fortunate today to go
it's me to go
well I have been very fortunate today to
go after uh des and I've been in
agreement with their positions uh the
New Hampshire Municipal Association does
support this bill we view this as a
forward forward thinking piece of
legislation
um and really it's over the past few
years we've had a number of different
natural disasters strike our our state
so if I can just bring your mind back to
July of 2021 there was a pretty severe
rainstorm that impacted the Southwest
part of the state
um and in response to that
um of course the people of the towns
called their local officials and asked
for help asked for
um you know what do we do next and local
officials turn around and called the
state
um and us and uh in response to some of
those natural disasters there's there's
legislation introduced last year
and passed last year by the legislature
to help address future uh natural
disasters and what the state could do
giving the state greater flexibility in
in helping respond because we all know
that the federal government is not
always the fastest in responding and
people need help now
um and so we're very grateful for that
and this kind of runs along the same
lines where there's a hole in our
current system where natural disasters
may occur
there are people who will be in need and
there do not appear to be other programs
um outside of whatever local assistance
that that towns could provide
um that would actually fill this hole
and so we are hopeful that that the
legislature will support this
legislation to give the appropriate
state agency greater flexibility and
some funds to deal with this in the
future
I'm happy to take any questions
any questions my members of the
committee
seeing no one
thank you very much
uh it's I'll declare these yeah I will
declare the hearing adjourned
and we asked we'll start again at one
o'clock
run down get your sandwich order a full
meal don't worry I I will I will start
the hearing but you can always catch it
yeah
sorry for the uh delay
we just got finished with the one
ran a little long uh this has had a
house bill 472 relative to the placement
of temporary seasonal docks
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee for listening to my testimony
my name is Carol Crawford I represent
Carol District 3 the towns of
moultonborough
Tamworth and
um Madison it is a new it is a new
District I bring before I use house bill
472. it was never my intention to
um
have permanent docs eliminated it's my
intention from constituents to give more
oversight for temporary docs on the lake
I don't live on Lake Winnipesaukee but I
have a lot of
constituents that do and I was contacted
about a temporary doc that was being
placed near a loon nesting Center and
when they notified d-e-s-d-e-s said they
really had no control over that because
they have no permitting and so when they
contacted me and I read what temporary
Docs
criteria was I thought well I think
maybe Des needs a little more control
over that and I probably would have to
amend this because I've been told that
it's pretty Broad and if I could say
that I
might take out Wildlife species because
that certainly is a lot to
cover and threatening species or
endangered species might be more
appropriate but I guess I would look to
this committee to give me some guidance
or to Des or a fishing game maybe and
come to some type of a compromise
and I'm certainly not an expert on
and that's my testimony which is
testimony any questions any questions by
okay
uh actually oh
uh yep all right representative Darby
Berg thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking my question yes I I think the
term uh explicitly
um any Wildlife species that phrase
needs to be struck
um and uh the the RSA that it refers to
is about threatening while uh threatened
endangered wildlife and loons as far as
common loons as far as I understand in
the in uh New Hampshire are threatened
and so they would they would qualify
actually someone just walked in
I am certain knows
all about docs and was part of the
committee that a part of a commission
that
uh
we he and I and chaired by uh
representative uh
I forgot his name now but anyway the uh
on on temporary Docs and you your your
issue again is that uh there is whereas
there were
uh the emperor there were a loons near a
temporary dock yes and uh
I hate to hit you with it from out of
nowhere uh running do you but uh
when you have a protected species you're
a temporary dock do we cover that during
our
that Commission
we did not cover that okay thank you but
uh can you recall whether they're uh uh
that is was I think representative Darby
said that uh because the the loons are a
prospective species that
they are they are protected or
you know from from a from a temporary
Dock and even though they're they're no
longer under permit they still could be
affected by the uh by the law
oh that might help that might help you
but right but uh anyway well let's
continue with the with the process I'm
sorry uh that's quite all right thank
you Mr chairman it could be a little bit
I could be a little bit helpful uh any
other questions uh by members of the
committee
Zena thank you very much
uh
in opposition uh Chris Norwood for uh
foreign
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
um I think that uh what representative
said in her opening testimony is really
where I want to hit upon which is the
lack of clarity
um so I appreciate the comments that
were already made relative to all
Wildlife species but where I would
specifically like to address the
committee's attention is
um
what are the impacts for the property
owner so uh I should apologize my name
is Chris Norwood and I am the 2023 chair
of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors public policy committee and we
are in opposition to this bill
and we're certainly not in opposition to
wanting to put a seasonal dock on top of
a loon's nest but that is something we
do not want to see where we have
concerns is if you look at all of the
other stipulations within the um
uh
within the bill excuse me
I can't find the piece of paper
when you look into all the permitting
under RSA 482 the vast majority of those
letters those numbers 1 through 10 are
something that you could do as a
layperson as a property owner but we're
unsure if this new piece of legislation
would trigger a survey and who
ultimately would conduct that survey
would it be conducted by the Department
of Environmental Services which is my
understanding they have jurisdiction
over seasonal docs or by going into RSA
212 which deals with endangered species
that becomes more of a fish and game
jurisdiction is this something that
could be done administratively over the
computer whereby there's a survey of
maps that showcase where these
endangered species would be or is this
something rather that you would need to
hire a professional that would need to
come to your property and to conduct
that survey
and again the concern being that the
majority of these items here you know
distance from your neighbor Etc are
things that a layperson could do so that
was one concern and then the other
concern is this in general the word
impact itself again we do not want to
see a seasonal dock on top of a nest I
think that that's something that is very
clear-cut but the word impact could also
be the the migration pattern of the Loon
which going back to the property owner
the layperson I'm not sure that that the
lay person would be able to interpret
the word impact if there was an
endangered species that traveled through
their property so many times a year so I
think uh the bill needs some edits in
order to protect the private property
rights of the individual and I apologize
for stumbling earlier in the testimony
representative wrong for a question
thank you Mr chair and and thank you Mr
Norwood for taking my question a couple
questions
um when you raise the issue about the
word impacted if the word negatively was
inserted before impacted so negatively
impact would that resolve your concern
thank you representative for the
question
um I don't think it's the word negative
or positive impact I think it's
specifically the word impact
um
maybe needing a a word at the end of
impact if it's negatively impacting The
Nest I think that again the layperson
could look at a nest and understand that
they're hitting their dock is going to
go on a nest that's something that's
easily distinguishable but if the
favorite food of the endangered species
happens to live near where your seasonal
Dock and I wouldn't know that as a
layperson
that's where there's vagary in that word
is it the impact of the the breeding
grounds is it impact of their traveling
is it impact of their
eating grounds that's that's the vagary
behind the the word it needs a modifier
that's what that's it I think it needs a
modifier on the back end of it okay
follow up Mr chair thank you
and this kind of goes in along with that
so
um when you're you're let me see
um
so your concern I'm I'm trying to find
out if do you have a suggested remedy
that would make this bill
um be one that the Realtors could
support I I appreciate the question
representative so a lot of my work all
of my work is done in the commercial
real estate world and you may be
familiar if you in the state disturb
roughly two acres of land it triggers an
alterations of terrains permit which
would in that instance invite in a
number of state agencies including fish
and game
um to to conduct a survey of the in most
cases commercial property being
developed that would necessitate a study
of the the fishing game within that
community
so what I would like to see is some
clarification is that what we're talking
about because I'm not sure
are we asking for the equivalent of an
alteration of terrains permit Fish and
Game portion of an aot being inserted
for a seasonal dock
and if so what those costs would be and
if that's something that is done
administratively I my Layman's
understanding of that piece because I'm
not an engineer is that there are
databases that suggest territorial areas
where endangered species live so can it
be done administratively on a computer
or is it something that would require an
in-person boots on the ground survey and
again what are the costs what are the
timelines surrounding those so so those
are the areas where I'd like to
understand a little bit more how a
property owner would get Des
sign off on this new bullet point 11.
can you indulge me for one more
follow-up Mr chair for a follow-up okay
um
but you're talking about property owner
and I recognize that the owner owns the
dock but the property we're talking
about is water that's under State
control so would it would it satisfy
your concerns if the property owner was
notified by it could be the loom
preservation Alliance working with fish
and game or Des to inform them that
where their dock is located over the
state waters that it's posing a negative
impact to an endangered species
I think it's a great question
representative and if there was a if we
understood better the mechanism in
the only way that I have been able to
interpret it is through the lens of
alteration of terrain's permits and if
we better understood the mechanism and
we better understood the definition of
that word impact I think it could be
something that would be agreeable again
we're not looking to have a doc go right
over
that Nest but there's a lot of other
vagaries that we'd like clarified thank
you very much thank you thank you Mr
chair
representative wolf for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um this does not
specify
who is going to give you a certification
or even if you need a certification
it prohibits it so if you call somebody
from the Audubon Society and come up and
look at your property or know that your
property is exempt that may satisfy or
if you have a friend who does Wetland
studies and does this I mean the aot
permit says a hundred thousand square
feet
do you know what a hundred thousand
square feet is by looking at it no you
have to go out and get somebody that
tells you what it is and I think and the
question then is
does this require a certification or
just knowledge that it's in a prohibited
area
representative wolf thank you for uh
asking the question I would say that's
the concern is is the lack of clarity is
so who's who is um
the legislation doesn't as I see it
contemplate whose standard uh is giving
the sign off on this bullet point 11.
and whether or not it could be you know
the the Audubon Society or fishing game
or perhaps
cription for a follow-up follow-up
um thank you
is there a sign off needed I don't
interpret this as a sign off being
needed it just says you can't put it
where it's prohibited
representative thank you for the
follow-up I would defer to the folks
from Des who were the ones that
administer the permits and perhaps they
could shed some light if if a new
standard is inserted
how they would
um they would look to an applicant to
prove either yay or nay on that bullet
point 11.
yeah
is that it move a follow-up or yes okay
thank you
I think that this all
rule exempts you from getting a permit
yes you just have to file notice to Des
and if you file notice you're saying
that it's not in a prohibited area
you're saying that it's more than 30
feet so Des does not issue
and there's somebody here from Des or a
permit so I believe that it's incumbent
upon the property owner
to comply with these 11 statements
yes representative I I think the use of
my use of the word permit was uh
inappropriate notification is perhaps
the better word
the the law I mean that's going to all
come back to me now the uh the commit
the commission that met uh on exactly
this issue of uh uh permits or or the
the the not a need for a permit for
temporary docs and if you met the
certain requirements
uh that are listed in here you then did
need a permanent cut you didn't have to
apply for a permit ever each and every
year uh so so this would not was would
this issue with species would would uh
unless they were there to to at the
beginning
wouldn't wouldn't have wouldn't apply so
if someone sees species there or makes a
complaint that would then go to if I'm
not mistaken the uh fishing game
um I would think and this is in other
words but it was it's not
prohib it's
right but it will it will but then and
if that then occurs
then then there's issues about about the
about the dock uh but it it can affect
the permit because it's not allowed but
again I'm not uh I don't want to Mr
chair if I could yeah and again I think
uh representative wolf I I again
apologize because I think my use of the
word permit uh was inappropriate and
when you go to the word notification I
still think it goes back to the original
portion of of the testimony whereby we
had the discussion about um impact so
we're we're in favor if we can come to
some agreement with how that gets
adjudicated you know in your example Mr
chair
um a third party Witnesses uh endangered
species traveling the property notifies
Des would that then harm your renewal
the next time you go to file the
notification again is the impact based
upon
um seasonal travelings nesting speeding
ground
I'm not sure I think that there is a
solution in the middle I just think we
need to find it
I don't believe there uh there there is
no re once you get the permit
you have it
now uh and I think uh unless there's a
complaint to the Des and that would be
my point yes or or somebody complains to
the uh fishing game
that that would then trigger some some
other than that it's uh if someone can
if if they find that they're out of
compliance
they can they have to deal with that
uh
I'm seeing none thank you Mr chair thank
you members
um
and
have written copies of testimony from
the waste management advisory committee
from New Hampshire followed as well as
from Williamson
oh wait a minute
hi what do we have here oh this is about
to say three different letters three
different letters and they're all going
that way
foreign
however despite those intensive efforts
built in half the holyness excuse me
uh down down below there we are good
okay
okay let's try that again there we are
all right it looks like it's staying on
this time
um so as as I was saying despite lpc's
intensive management efforts close to
half of loon nests fail every year the
recovery of loons in New Hampshire to
date has been hard won the growth of the
population has been just 2.1 percent per
year over the past 10 years and loon
numbers are still well below their
historical levels despite lpc's
intensive research management and
Outreach to help them
New Hampshire's Wildlife action plan
lists Shoreline protection as an
objective for loons and other species
and this proposed legislation is a step
to help achieve that goal
and therefore LPC supports efforts to
protect threaten and endangered species
from disturbance from dogs whether they
are permanent or temporary during
critical nesting periods and that
concludes my testimony I would be happy
thank you
okay
we have any questions by members of the
committee representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh can you address the
current concern earlier about how the
word impact could be rewarded rewarded
to identify the areas that a layperson
could identify where they could not
there we go
um yes thank you for the for the
question
um in terms of of impacts I think the
the most critical period of elune's life
cycle is when they are nesting that's
when they are tied to place and and they
cannot easily escape from an obstruction
recreational use of the lake or some
other uh form and so that represents a
real bottleneck to the loom population
as we said close to half of our lewdness
fail every year despite these intensive
uh efforts to to protect them uh so
certainly one One impact of of note
would be a nest failure or the potential
to have a nest failure my thought as I
was reading this this bill was that um
if if there is a dock that is close to a
loon Nest I don't think that loon cares
if it's a permanent or seasonal dock to
that loon it's just a dock and it would
have the same impact whether it was
permanent or or seasonal uh and so my my
um thought and and I'm no expert in this
by any means but if we apply the same
standards as we do to a permanent doc to
a temporary dock that would go a long
way towards addressing these issues and
I believe that impacts to loons they are
probably defined by Department of
Environmental Services in New Hampshire
fishing in-game for permanent docks if
we could apply that same
level of scrutiny to the temporary docs
I think that that would probably address
for a follow-up thank you Mr chair thank
you
so
being someone that has a temporary doc
seasonal temporary Doc and on a lake
where we have an increasing Lumen
population
and
um having seen
loon's nest in an area of this last year
where they had not previously nested how
would a homeowner account for that case
how would they say you know no oh it may
be the dot maybe the Loon is nesting on
my property this year
yeah so every year the Loon preservation
committee submits all of the details of
loon nesting areas and these are
geolocated so you submit those to the
natural heritage Bureau and at that
point they become part of that inventory
and I believe that if there is a a um at
this point if there's a permit for a a
permanent Dock and it falls within it
may be 50 meters or 50 yards might be
100 yards that gets flagged for review
by Department of Environmental Services
I would imagine that perhaps the same
the same thing would be true for a
seasonal bucks uh if something if
legislation such as this were enacted
thank you
representative wolf our question if you
put the same restrictions on a temporary
dock that you're putting on a permanent
dock that defeats the whole purpose of a
permanent permit by negot
the permit by notification
so you're making it very difficult for
somebody to put in a temporary dock just
by notifying des and meeting the 11
requirements
so if you follow the requirement for a
permanent talk
that's quite a bit more stringent than
what this
permit by notification is am I not
correct
um thank you for the question
representative I am not an expert on on
permitting docs by any means I would
think that if Department of
Environmental Services or New Hampshire
fishing game is the actual agency that
does that permitting procedure the
extent of the Loon preservation
committee's involvement in the past has
been to to send this data on the
location of where Lou nests are and on
occasion if there is a a request for a
doc a permanent doc that flags that then
we will we will respond with comments to
Department of Environmental Services or
for a follow-up
so what you just stated is that Des
knows where the loans are by your
notification every year yes so there is
clearly then a way either for the
homeowner or Des when the notice permit
by notification is applied for
to know whether there's a loon Nest May
or not
I believe yes once a once a permit for a
permanent dock is is submitted if there
is a loon nesting within that certain
distance then we are notified and I
would I would imagine that um one way of
of accomplishing this legislation might
be to to have that same requirement for
a temporary dog but again I'm I'm I
really can only speak to impacts of uh
representative wrong for a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um you mentioned how the Loon
preservation Alliance
surveys Lakes to determine where nesting
grounds might be and they pass that
information on which ultimately gets to
Des are there other organizations in New
Hampshire that also do that or do all
the Loon nests in the state
we are balloon preservation committee is
is really the organization that that
collates that so we have a large network
of volunteers and small paid staff and
uh so we will go out and Survey Lakes
about 360 Lakes uh this past summer not
all of those Lakes have loons on them
but all of them have the potential to
have loons we hope more of them will
have loons in the future and in the
course of of that surveying uh whether
that's uh whether we get that
information from our our seasonal field
biologists from our volunteers or from
anybody else in in the public while we
will incorporate that into our database
which then gets submitted to the natural
foreign
representative gold yes thank you for
taking my question
um just to curiosity
a person has a
um a regular dog
and then
alone decides to put a nest near it how
is that taken care of
yes uh thank you for the the question
representative and and uh it's a it's a
good question uh I I know of certain
instances where loons have nested quite
close to docs and other other structures
if that dock is already there and that
loon nests close to it we will attempt
to work with the landowner and and uh
and see what can be what can be done to
minimize you know disturbance and
impacts to those to those loons
um on uh in fact on some there's an
island on Squam Lake
um perch Island uh where the where the
owners of their cabin actually will not
come to their cabin until after the Loon
has finished nesting um and and leaves
not all of you know property owners are
that accommodating but we attempt to
work with them in order to to have that
no one else thank you very much thank
you
I know it said
and it was kind of unfair to hit people
with uh with a question and I noticed
that the uh chair of the aforementioned
commission uh that on on temporary docs
uh if if you if I mean
the issue is around a
loon
uh what happened with a loom starts uh
nesting on a
uh near a temporary dock did we do
anything I don't believe we did much of
anything on that maybe you uh uh might
want
I want to comment on that if you could
but if you you know if you if if you
don't you don't uh okay if you yeah if
for the record this is representative
McConkey
thank you Mr chairman um
um I am um representative Mark McConkey
I was appointed to head the commission
uh as your illustrious chairman I
believe was on that commission and and
former representative Smith also we
tackled a lot of discussion uh but this
mention of the Loon population
uh in proximity to Temporary docks was
was never an item that we considered nor
was it brought to the commission and
mentioned that it was an issue either so
I I would have we had representation
the Department of Environmental Services
and others on the commission so I'm
not certain why if if the problem had
Rose to that degree that we didn't hear
it
and since you've asked me to be here Mr
chairman I've signed in against the bill
because I think the language is too open
when it says I believe in there it talks
about any Wetlands or any vegetation and
I would just hope that maybe this is one
of those bills that should be held back
and thought more about but not brought
forward I when we worked on the
commission we tried to find ways of
streamlining processes looking at what
the biggest issues were to date with uh
temporary Docs
and um
I as much as I love the department when
we pass legislation I think we should
say tighter what we intend and not have
rules propagated after the fact that the
legislature
does not have the availability to weigh
in on so it would be my hope at very
thank you and could you put in a card
yes thank you I would be happy to thank
you
all right
you know just like maybe I I didn't ask
the anyone was any members of the
committee have a question
seeing none
oh
who's that oh yeah it's representative
he was fat he was faster on the
drawing my Jeopardy yeah when you were
ready you were raising your hand and he
had to play his own butt
in a letter that we just got from Carol
Foss of the Audubon Society she said
that the
natural New Hampshire natural heritage
Bureau keeps a list of where loans are
I'm summarizing the wording in there so
it would be relatively simple for
somebody to request a check from the
natural heritage Bureau before they
install their dock
um thank you for the question
representative and it's it does sound
like an easy process I'm a practitioner
I do a lot of Permitting for different
things Wetlands Shoreland and everything
else
they it's it
there is a website that you go to and
you identify as best you can where these
things are and you almost immediately
get
a response that there is something
whether it be an invasive species a loon
or something and your process stops
and then you make application again
twenty five dollars and if I remember
correctly you have to send that through
the mail because that for some reason
the state doesn't accept a debit so
again we're we're on to it and many many
times no adverse effect and then you're
then your process works on again
so it's it's a time delay
if I were if I were asking to and if I
could miss chairman
um if I were asking to construct a
building in the shoreline and the uh a
bat population happened to be in the
area and after the naturalist comes out
and identifies whether there is a bat
and I believe fish and game has to come
out identify if that loon is still there
or that nesting area
I don't mean to belittle that the
population
um then on the on the
on the bat the long-eared I can't don't
know the full name of the bat then
you're told to delay all construction
for three or four months during whatever
the breeding period is and and the time
that they're close so if something were
going to be done I would like to see
conditions
um permitting in some way but not but
not to take the way the right from the I
hate to say for the homeowner but if
you're on a small pond
you severely limit the value of that
property if people can't have a
temporary Dock and some of these are
foreign
than representative Darby thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question
um I want to follow up on a comment you
made when you stated you were opposed to
this bill because the language was too
open and I realized in the title it it
uh or the analysis it mentions Wetlands
permitting but in the statute that's
being amended it it specifically says
lake or Pond and I was wondering do you
think that is is that the language it's
too open
no
um and I apologize I wasn't planning on
sitting here I if I I believe
Mr chairman I don't have the bill in
front of me yeah
would you give me a moment too yeah no
that's okay and I'm
uh
quickly on line three it states
temporary seasonal docs installed on any
lake or pond so I was just wondering if
if in your opinion that language is too
open or if it was some other area of the
my thank you representative Mike my my
issue was not with that my issue is
line 25 number 11. prohibited for being
placed in an area that will impact any
Wildlife species threatened species or
endangered species in accordance with
any Wildlife species threatened species
indeed I believe that leaves a lot open
to interpretation got it and I would
like that language tightened up okay
thank you thank you
if the representative Darby
um just a question are we going to hear
from Des do you know uh no
they think no okay
um
so I want to make sure we're talking
about the same tool the national natural
heritage uh Bureau data check tool
because uh we received an email from
um commissioner Scott are also referring
to the National Heritage Bureau data
check tool which said that it was
available online and that sounds like a
very different process than the one I
just heard you describe about sending in
25 and having this back and forth and I
want to make sure we're talking about
the same same tool to be able to access
what is you know where the the
endangered and Fenton species are thank
you thank you thank you represent they
so you start out you start out in the
process by going to the website and
finding this tool from the natural
heritage that's on there it costs you
nothing to start an application so you
go in and you either give the
coordinates longitude latitude or
there's a tool to drop you in on the map
and then drop you in by parcel and then
you put a dot where where you intend to
do your work
so you fill out who the owner is what it
is you want to do and then you hit send
and it goes to the bureau and within a
day or two sometimes longer they will
report back to you that your project has
no impact and you're good to proceed or
you will get a hit that says it appears
we have something in that area and
they'll give you a list that it could be
anything from a specialty grass to
an endangered species
whatever it might be and it'll say that
you cannot move forward until further
investigation is done and to move
forward you I believe the fees 25
you need to continue on your application
send them 25 dollars through the U.S
mail and once they receive receipt of
that then they will Churn it to whomever
they need to to go investigate that
thanks very much
foreign
I'm not going to ask for any more
questions I apologize
I sincerely apologize calling you up
here on unnoticed
and in help giving giving the
giving us the benefit of your it is
always a pleasure to be in the presence
seeing uh no other having no other uh
you know I love this okay we're doing
what questioned uh what what are we
doing we're on 274.
nothing
72. 472 because the next bill is 247. so
I said I don't know
yeah so we have we have no uh no further
pink cards on this bill that will close
the hearing
and we're
we'll start again on the next airing at
two o'clock oh I've got five minutes
oh we're late oh I'm sorry I'm still
here on the I'm still here in the
morning yeah
okay let's and then we start again we'll
start on uh house bill
uh
and uh Jesus
okay
uh
representative wolf
uh we're in we're in session
uh
again I apologize and I apologize again
for calling
calling a slate
yeah you do you believe me take your
time
47.
Senator McConkey
relative to protective well radii
the floor is yours thank you Mr chairman
it's still a pleasure to be before you
folks
the I am the prime sponsor of House Bill
which is a bill removes the encroachment
waivers uh required using a setback
reduction form and remove certain
requirements of an amended septic system
plan
I'm going to grab a little I worked
extensively with uh
Department of Environmental Services
department environmental services worked
with the Attorney General's office to
craft the language that you see before
you
I might steal a little bit of the
Thunder here on what they have and I'm
going to defer most of the questions uh
Mr Robert and the department that's here
but this this proposal would clarify and
streamline the process regarding the
protective radii around
private Wells radius as I would refer to
it it would eliminate the provision for
an encroachment waiver which is
redundant with deeded easements and
rarely used
and add more flexibility regarding
monitoring requirements simplifying
reporting
requirements and clarify ambiguous
sections of the statute
I had mentioned in the previous
testimony that I am a practitioner in
environmental permitting
I have
been permitted
to design septic systems installed in
septic systems for nearly 30 years I run
a family business and my two sons also
hold all the same permits
up in the north country where I am I
shouldn't say North because North is
much further north than me I'm in
Freedom the Conway area
I know they take exception if I saved
North Country so I apologize the
um we have a lot of lots that were
subdivided prior to the enactment of
State regulation we have a lot of tiny
Lots
uh 50 feet by 50 feet and so forth and
many of those lots that were created
before the time of subdivision and
before the regulation of departmental
services even today are still allowed to
have a septic system no larger than two
bedroom or or
300 gallons a day
providing and then the list starts
providing there's sufficient soil
providing that and the well radius now
becomes an issue
so Wells that were drilled before 1989
if if my sheet of paper and I won't use
it as a prop but if my sheet of paper
were the size of my lot and it had
dimensions of 50 feet along the water
and 75 back or 50 back and I was the
first one in the area what I would do or
what most of them did was they'd put
their house in the middle they'd put
their septic system in the front or
backyard and they would put their well
as far away from their own septic system
that they could
now back then many of the systems
weren't regulated so that seemed like a
great idea to that homeowner the problem
comes when the neighbor came along next
door or now when inventory is down and
there's so few lots and I'm looking for
a place to be
the rule was that if your
your radius was not completely contained
on your property and you wanted to get
closer to your neighbor
you had to get an encroachment waiver
they had to agree that I could put my
septic system
closer to your well than than what's
allowed today and many homeowners I've
run into it probably no less than a
hundred times would come out and say I'd
love to have you for a neighbor but I'm
not signing that document
today's world in the design and install
of septic system in
2023 is an extremely different process
than it was in 1987 and you have to have
permitted people determine what the
soils are and in some of these instances
where it's so small the Department of
Environmental Services would like to see
pre-treatment done and by pre-treatment
it's taking nitrates and phosphates out
and it's protecting that well next door
and it's also protecting your well-being
close by
so
this bill we talked about it last year
it was trailered on to another bill and
by the time it made it to the Senate
they thought it should stand on its own
so that's that's why we're back here
today there will also be people uh
besides septic uh professionals I
believe the water well board and others
are to follow me and
um and uh
and I would probably defer a lot of why
we need to do this because it benefits
well people also well drillers and how
they report but I'm happy to take
questions at this juncture if if that
there any questions by members of the
committee
chair calls Phil Philip throwbridge New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services
it's a good afternoon chairman renzulo
and members of the committee
uh for the record I'm Philip Trowbridge
administrator of the land resource
management program at New Hampshire des
and I appreciate the opportunity to
testify regarding House Bill 247 and the
department supports this bill and
sitting with me today is Brandon Kernan
who's the administrator of the
groundwater drinking water groundwater
Bureau of the uh since this bill deals
with both
septic system permitting as well as
so just by way of some background a
protective well radius is the circle
around a well representing the area from
which the water is drawn into the well
typically for a private well for
residents it's 75 feet radius
and this build build deals with these
situations where that radius extends off
of the lot on which the well exists so
it goes from the lot where someone owns
a well onto someone else's lot
um Des worked with representative
McConkey the water well board
the water well contractors septic system
designers and septic system installers
on this bill because the current statute
is very hard to implement
and it really could be streamlined
without reducing without increasing any
risks to Public Health of the
environment
so to help you understand the bill I've
attached some slides to the letter of
testimony that you all should have they
they illustrate some of these situations
where the well radius crosses lot lines
and tries to avoid overlap with houses
and septic systems
and the the testimony letter also has a
fair amount of detail as to why the
department supports the bill
but for the purpose of brevity today I'm
going to just highlight three issues and
then we can get into questions
um
first and I think foremost it's
important to understand that both the
rsas and Court decisions have
established that the portion of a
private well radius that extends off of
the well owners lot is not protected
it can't be used to prevent development
of that other lot
because that would be a takings from the
owner of that other lot
so unfortunately though one really has
to read between the lines in the statute
and understand the case law to know that
and we've handled lots of questions from
people who are calling us
and are confused by it so one of our
major goals is just to have some
affirmative language that landowners can
cannot read and understand their rights
a second major goal is to reduce
redundant reporting requirements
right now when we have one of these
situations with a well radius that goes
off the lot up to three different
reports need to be filed with two
different sections of Des some of which
need to be reported recorded with the
registry of deeds some of which need to
be signed by the abutting landowner
um really ultimately this can be
simplified to one report
it's called the setback reduction form
which the water well contractors are
already required under a different
statute to file with des and that we
uh third major change is to remove a
requirement to get an amended septic
plan if the well location needs to be
moved
so water well contractors have the
option to decide to move where they put
the well if they get on site and they
find that they can't get to the approved
location
you know I think we could all imagine
circumstances where we've got a plan and
it says put the well here but there may
be a steep slope or there may be power
lines or a really large tree
or something else and so they have the
ability to say you know we can't go here
but we can go here
and right now under the statute the
homeowner would then have to
rehire a septic system designer for a
second time
to amend their septic plan to show the
new location of the well
um
the
getting this this amendment really just
adds cost and time but not protection
because the water well contractors use
in these cases where they might have to
move the well they use these what are
called special methods of construction
which is like extra casing and grouting
and sealing of the well that's been
approved by the Water Well board to to
install the well safe leave and if it
has to be perhaps closer to the septic
system than was originally approved
so really doing this amended septic plan
is just a paper exercise after the fact
it's on the homeowner's responsibility
to hire someone to do it they have to
pay them a second time and oftentimes
they fail to do that and put themselves
so in summary we support this bill
because it first off removes removes
confusion about the protections for
private Wells
when the radius goes off lot
streamlines the reporting process
and it eliminates this unnecessary
requirement for an amended septic plan
all in all this saves landowners and
contractors time and money without
affecting property rights or increasing
risks
so we we thank you for this opportunity
and I'm sure you'll have questions and
any questions by members of the
committee
representative wrong thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question on
line 24 of the bill it it references the
water well contractor and I was
wondering is there does Des certify this
type of a position or their standards
they have to can anybody be a water well
contractor
um thank you representative everyone
could you specify which page oh I'm
sorry it's on page one page one okay
line 24. yeah
yeah uh and Brandon maybe you should
answer that
yes um in Statue it's established that
the Department of Environmental Services
helps administer the water well board
there's a water well board which is a
board of appointed members that um
oversee licensing of water well
contractors and different type of Wells
as well as pump installation
okay follow up Mr chair for a follow-up
so so it's safe to assume that when I
see water well contractor that it is
someone who's met the licensing
requirements of the state
yes and in fact you know where the board
is very active and cracking down on any
entity that might be operating without
the appropriate license okay thank you
any other questions by members of the
committee
oh
I
apologize for being such a big mouth but
thank you for all right Mr chair
um and thank you for taking my question
just
um
I'm trying to understand what the
original intent of these um of these uh
encroachment waivers were it basically
is hey I want to move my well on my land
but now my
um my radius would
um require would basically go onto your
property so I need you to approve that
and then my neighbor says
yes or no is that was that the idea like
to sort of guarantee that they have
protection
uh thank you representative Darby uh yes
I went back to when this bill was or
when the statue was originally created
in 1989
um and
um the intent was about the encroachment
of the well on the neighbor
um and to say that if you were
you know wanted to basically have your
well radius go off of the laws but you
wanted to control what could happen in
that area that was off the lot then you
needed to get a sign up from your
neighbor agreeing essentially that they
wouldn't put their septic system or you
know parking area or something there
over time it kind of shifted
to be the opposite of the well radius
goes across the lot and you know now
it's a question of the septic system
encroaching on it and really the point
here is to clarify that and bring it
any other questions by members of the
committee
saying none
thank you very much
dear recognizes
is that Chris Albert
oh okay representing granite state on
site
all right yep thank you chairman renzel
uh the committee rrd it's been a long
time since I've been here uh again Chris
Albert I'm for the record I'm chairman
of the Granite State rural uh uh Waters
uh granite state on site was Association
formerly gsdi uh very cumbersome with
our new name but we rebranded uh this is
an instrumental bill this is very
important for us if you look at the
second page that we sent that's kind of
a typical uh septic replacement that we
have to deal with uh with well radius is
overlapping uh uh this is a great bill
as as far as it's it's more of a
clerical bill as far as clearing up the
pre-89 Post 89 status
uh the encroachment waiver process the
recorded well-released documents that
we've had to do over the years doesn't
work it takes time uh I deal with a lot
of small lot septic designs Replacements
that are failed uh that causes delays on
again
as far as an environmental perspective
this bill won't cause any environmental
issues we're in very supportive of this
bill it's long overdue and again it's
pretty much a clerical uh upgrade to the
current law again I don't know if
there's any attorneys in the room but
again it was an attorney interpretation
over the years that's kind of Dennis to
this point right now so hopefully this
is there any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
last card
uh Bart Cushing
doesn't say whether you support it
whether you oppose it
doesn't say how long you want to speak
but
yeah
New Hampshire I'm an independent so I'm
not going to show my cards but no but uh
starting out I'm uh represent the New
Hampshire water well board I also am
past president New Hampshire water wall
Association
uh third generation driller our company
we serve over in the Keene area is where
we're headquartered out of we drove
throughout the state uh this is my 44th
year 45th year doing this
um we employed 23 people in New
Hampshire our industry is usually
family-run businesses we don't have any
conglomerates have tried to
to you know organize our whole industry
I've been involved with the licensing
since it started in 84.
and I will say that this whole program
with this going through this this
process right now has been wonderful
um unlike in pastimes when we were told
how far to put Wells and where to put
them it came very from the top down and
we're the last ones to know this time
has had really good Outreach sought our
support
um it's it's really welcomed in our
industry we have had a couple meetings
about with us about this we're all
supportive of it it offers us Clarity
and the best thing it does without
encroaching on environmental or
landowner rights it cuts red tape and
that's a the winning thing right there
again today how many calls we feel from
Wells that were put in earlier where
they put in before you had to release
form were they registered with the Deeds
I can't find it was it previous
legislation or after this legislation
and it has really provided clarity
our industry we have special
construction methods that have been
adopted by the board we're putting
additional casing in not only because of
encroachment issues but you may have
contamination issues contamination can
be if we've all heard of peepas MB mtbe
other things other than just septic and
just addressing the septic is we have
very few if any reported cases from
drilled artesian wells that have been
done within the last 30 years where
septics have affected the water quality
the potability it's kind of a big deal
something in our industry we're quite
proud of and this adopting these methods
of special construction methods have
really helped our to deliver a better
product to our customers and we're a lot
of the state as you know is not sourced
by Public Water Supplies
um we don't see any environmental
degradation with this bill it also
allows us to stay out of the wetlands a
lot of times the designers are putting
the well literally five feet from the
shore on Winnipesaukee or Spofford or
anything and you had to drill the well
there that was it period you did not
we're not given license to go put it
wherever you wanted to even with special
construction if you did you took it at
your own Hazard then you'd have to ask
the designer to come back and do what's
called an as built and the as belt is
kind of like throwing to some people a
carte blanche card they could charge you
a hundred dollars for that they could
charge you a thousand dollars for that
that's as built that's outside of what
you hired them for initially so this has
provided a lot of help to everybody
without with we just see it as a
win-win-win all the way around
and I I did want to again praise the
Outreach
um on my on a personal issue I had a
septic I had to upgrade my septic at my
house and I submitted the plans on a
Tuesday afternoon I got my approval on a
Wednesday morning
unheard of I
I just think you know what we've seen
with Don Bucher who's hadn't met she
came and provided some of the initial
Outreach I can't say enough good about
how that's been a collaborative effort
and our industry is fully supportive as
is the legislative New Hampshire water
wall board the who oversees the
Contracting licensing testing of the
contractors in our industry
anyone from Nick have any questions from
representative Darby
thank you chairman thank you pay no
attention to me I'm only kidding you're
you're doing good uh thank you for
taking my question I I think I get it
but I just want to make sure
um so you know you don't you don't want
to file this amended plan because that's
the red tape
but um are you still filing with where
the actual Wells going where you're
actually Drilling and you know how it's
how it's constructed
yes it does not relieve the contractor
of the filing requirement it actually
puts it in one document instead of three
and so on a water well report uh you
have to file a a report on how the well
was drilled how many feet of casing a
complete drill log how far it was to
bedrock what were the soils that you
encountered
Etc and then the casing and the grouting
if it was done on these special you know
non they call them non-conforming
previous you had to have have a form
such a non-conforming form filed are
filed with the registry deeds and also
signed by the customer and essentially
said if your well gets can gets polluted
by the neighbor's septic system that you
can't hold the neighbor or the state
liable for it well okay that does that
really protect you maybe it does the
proper construction methods is a whole
lot better than a pile of papers but
this puts the document in one location I
hope I answered your question
any more questions from uh from members
of the committee
seeing none
hi thank you very much for your
testimony and I'm certain that the
gentleman from Des are happy to have
heard your testimony and giving them the
accolades that you feel they deserve so
you that was being the last
pink card
and he's going to close the hearing and
and the next hearing is
there's 488 yeah uh 488 is uh up at 2
30.
yes
did you hear from representative post on
this yes yeah are we going to open and
thank you chair and members of the
committee
um my name is representative Juliet
Harvey bully as you know and I'm uh this
is representative Lisa post's Bill and
she is unable to to attend today
um so I'm just going to very briefly
introduce it uh and it is a constituent
bill
the reason for the bill was that a
constituent couldn't get um
a reservation at a New Hampshire State
Park
um
and the uh
let's see
the the idea behind the bill is to allow
New Hampshire residents first come first
served over other states but we found
out that
there's Federal requirements and
stipulations that go along with the
receiving Federal monies
for New Hampshire state parks and so
they cannot be choosy in that way uh so
the sponsor wishes to do uh interim
study for the bill
is my understanding
and they are not interested in pursuing
the bill at this time
and so
that's all I have to say about it okay
thank you
Alex entertain no questions
so uh we uh also uh Mr Brian Wilson uh
from uh dncr uh he has requested he has
he didn't know that uh this is coming
until right now he does have uh some a
presentation he's gonna we're in some uh
some paperwork that he used like to give
us for uh
for for information uh and he likes is
just to give a brief uh synopsis of what
he'd uh what he would have planned would
had planned to say for 10 minutes
but for Less now yes it will be less yes
Mr Wilson the floor is yours thank you
uh thank you chairman and um good
afternoon committee members
um uh yeah my apologies for not um
having the latest uh up to date of where
where this bill stands
um so our Our Testimony maybe here a
little bit but I'm just going to quickly
just summarize and not read everything
um in into the record here today but um
the department uh appreciates the
concern of the bill but we respectfully
oppose the bill primarily because it uh
would violate
um the land and water conservation act
which is a federal act uh administered
through the National Park Service
virtually all of our state park
campgrounds have received Federal
funding through that program which has a
um discrimination Clause
um based on um that we cannot
discriminate based on residency
um primarily for uh the access to there
is language within the testimony here
that speaks to our our ability to apply
um uh separate but measured fee
structures for non-residents but in
terms of our ability to provide
preferential Acts success in this
people being able to reserve for a
period of time prior to non-residents
would be a violation of of of that law
and we we have had instances where this
has come up in the past primarily with
our ski areas a Cannon Mountain and
Sunapee where we've looked to be able to
issue passes for residents
prior to issuing to non-residents and we
we have had
correspondence from the National Park
Service that that that that would not
work for us so that is uh the the
primary reason uh the secondary reason
is more than the mechanics of our
reservation system
um does not really allow for a system to
differentiate between residents or
non-residents um over 90 percent of the
reservations that are made are done
online
and you can go in and create a profile
and put your address as anywhere in the
world if you want to and we don't really
have uh there is no mechanism within the
system to to verify that at the time of
reservation the time that that it could
be verified would be
um at the check-in time that creates
additional steps for us to make any
changes to that reservation so that
would be a very complex Endeavor for us
to have to go through
um possibly even finding an entirely
different vendor to provide our software
support for for the reservation system
so I think I'll leave it at that thank
you thank you thank you very much any
questions by members of the committee
seeing none
uh
all right
you may what
you you realize where this would build
this bill is not good we're we're not
going to be taking this bill Beyond
uh no you can ask him a question you
just put this into the uh in uh for your
it will be in or studied and that's it
so yeah
Lisa post
didn't know
within the bill
no at any rate thank you very much and
by the way we didn't find out about this
uh not being heard of until the quarter
of one
so
I'm sorry if you had to you have to come
out so happy to be here thank you thank
you bye-bye